Hello. Sweet bitches. Yeah. You
know? Yeah. I am talking to you,
dude.
Relax.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
is brought to you by 1-800-FLOWERS,
Tommy buns. You need some 1-800-FLOWERS
in your life. Flowers. Look at that.
It's got a little, Hello Joe
Rogan listeners. That's cute.
This is the first time we've ever done
the commercial too. They're preparing.
These motherfuckers are there in the game.
I want to flower budget like a hotel.
He should just have flowers in there.
I love seeing flowers.
Flowers are beautiful. It's
a very feminine thing now.
It's a very controversial,
if you're a man, you go pick flowers and
you live by yourself, you're suspect.
You'd definitely see you're going
to fold under pressure. You know,
guys think like that. Sure, but
why? Because they're idiots.
Flowers are fucking fantastic.
They're beautiful.
They're some of the most amazing
creations that nature has to offer.
What I love about something
like flowers.com or any florist,
I love when you have flowers that are
in the section of the grocery store that
represents to me like a
masterpiece of nature.
You know the and the fact that
you can get them delivered.
This is the most ridiculous thing ever.
It's incredible. Flowers are fantastic.
I wish we should all be surrounded
with flowers were just scared.
We don't want to be soft.
Yeah,
and you never feel weird about like if
you go to like a museum or some hotel or
some really rich person's house that
has like garden, like well cared for,
you know what I mean? They have a staff
that does their garden, those flat,
everybody stands in Awe,
right? Of like this.
It's nature's color Palette
running through their yard
and there's crazy flowers
everywhere and no one
feels weird about that.
Why don't more men like grow
gardens of flowers? Amazing.
We're going to uncover this time,
it's on this movement.
We're going to get to the bottom of this,
especially with 1-800-FLOWERS now
being in part of this podcast,
one 800 flowers.com as a special offer
on their holiday arrangements and fields
of Europe. It's the most popular
bouquet of the seasons. It's really,
really beautiful stuff.
It's hand designed, unique
arrangement of roses, lilies,
carnations, and it's all wrapped
up in a bright red ribbon.
The c'mon Tommy Buns. Look at
that. It's that, that makes your,
your table look better.
It makes me happy to walk into your
house and see that on the table.
But what if my house was all gangster
and every other way that would be even
better. Even better fed like I was in
the middle of skinning an animal. Yeah,
come on over time to wall of the Ar 15.
So making a fire with Flint
and you're like, just check
out my flowers. Look at my
flowers telling me buns.
Pretty Nice. I let them from one, 800
flowers, my friend. It's really beautiful.
And you see in the picture,
if you're watching on Ustream,
if you can't see it on Ustream,
chicks dig that Shit, dude.
Just go buy it for chicks.
If not even for yourself.
If you can't bring yourself to it,
if you to homophobic or you're too scared.
Are you scared of femininity?
I used to kid
the, yeah, don't be scared.
Don't be scared. homey.com.
Um, it's beautiful. And, uh,
if you order fields of Europe,
which is that bouquet that
we're looking at right there.
I don't know why fields of Europe,
I guess,
cause all those beautiful flowers grow
in Europe. I'll have to ask somebody a,
if you ordered them for
Christmas arrangement,
you'll receive a $10 off starting at just
29 99 plus it's available for same day
delivery. So if you like,
fuck, I forgot checks,
you can like boom, cover your
ass. Same Day delivery. Uh,
don't wait to send this
impressive Christmas arrangement
and save 10 bucks off
hurried. Or now sale ends
Friday, December 13th,
which is in two days.
What's today?
Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday, Friday.
So three days. That's beautiful.
What do you feel me? So that's
beautiful. Flowers at the MGM grand.
I was walking through, I saw, I was like,
I can take a picture of these
fucking beautiful flowers.
Maybe we can change people's perception.
Maybe people would be nicer if they have
flowers in their home. Is that possible?
I think so.
You can also get one that you can download
the mobile app and you can order it.
Um, you can order flowers from
that which is pretty bad ass.
So like on the fly on the, on
the trolley as it were, uh,
click on the microphone in the upper
right hand corner and enter my code,
which is j r. E. I'm trying
to get everyone to use that.
Hopefully they'll comply,
but thank God 1-800-FLOWERS
did it on their own.
That's one 800 flowers.com and enter in
the code j r e on the microphone on the
upper right hand corner. Go
there, do that. Enjoy you will,
you will like it and it'll make
your life like a little sweeter.
A little nicer spike just, you know,
just a little nicer Tommy buttons.
It's like a pumpkin spice latte. What's
wrong with the order and that just that,
that is something sweet. Just a
little something to make. Make Nice,
make Nice, nice everywhere. Big Flower
advocate guys, the flower advocate.
We're also brought to you by ting.com
a tang is one of my favorite companies
that we use here on, uh, on the podcast.
And one of the reasons being is I like
when a company does something like this,
they just gave you a no bullshit
cell phone option. Sweet.
Chris Ryan who was on a podcast all
the time, the author of sex at dawn,
he loves him. He just started using
it and saving them money and it works.
They use sprint a sprint's great.
You could, it was everywhere.
You can get Internet on it and can do
everything he can on a regular cell phone,
but you don't have to have a contract.
You can cancel anytime you want.
You don't have to worry about all the
bull shit that you usually get when you're
dealing with cell phones. It can be
a gigantic fucking pain in the ass.
They offer top of the line android
devices, which is what I use now.
I told you that's how he buns.
I switched to the Samsung Galaxy note.
Look at this screen.
I got off the apple tit.
My friend has it feel it feels
good to be free of the tit.
I thought about using a windows laptop,
but then I woke up.
I really did think about it is you
can ask him. That's a beautiful,
what's a good windows laptop?
I like changing things up and even
if it's for no fucking reason,
I don't know why, but I do. I
like changing things up. Do you,
do you miss any of the familiarity
of the APPS, ms? A few APPS,
but only a couple of them like
getting on Twitter. No problem.
Shizam no problem.
There's just a few of them that you miss.
Just download or an awesome I have today,
but the Instagram one sucks of fat one.
If you're out there Instagram coders,
how dare you?
How dare you try to pass this clunky
android version of a simple and elegant
iPhone APP. Get it to get the
bitches can't be that hard,
but if you want to get a bad ass
cell phone sim, Tim has mall,
they have the note three.
They have the galaxy s four
which I probably should have got,
which is probably the right size.
I think the galaxy phone and the HTC
one which is also very, very dope.
I think that's the right size.
I think that's a little too big.
I think I'm being silly.
I think with that is,
is like I'm on the rebound from apple.
I'm like fuck you. So I dated like this,
like really blonde guy and I went right
to a fucking African, just dark as shit.
And now I'm like,
I don't know if this is going to work out.
I missed some of the characteristics
of the blonde guy, you know,
miss the lack of bruising, you
know, so that's what you're like,
I feel it. I'm on the rebound. Yeah.
If I was a girl, that's my analogy.
That's a big one right there.
Rebounded with a big boy. Yeah.
Just fucking tired of your
bullshit. Um, ting is, um,
one of the nice things about
Ting also is you can uh,
bring over phones if you
have them on sprint. If you
have a nexus five on sprint,
um, you just, you can order a sprint
Sim card from them in order to, uh,
bring your coverage or
your device over to ting.
So just go to the bottom
of the devices page.
And tink doesn't sell the nexus five,
but you can purchase one from the
Google play store and easily, uh,
bring it over to ting.
Um,
the best thing about it is you don't
like if you want to cancel, like if your,
if your cell phone doesn't work in your
house and sometimes you don't know until
you get one and then you're like, what
the fuck? You know, at t and t works here,
but you know that Verizon doesn't
or whatever. That's annoying.
Um, if you can't get cell phone service
at work or at school or wherever the fuck
you're going, you're probably
gonna want to switch companies.
What have you tried to do that with
a big company? You're fucking doomed.
300 pay out the ass.
It's because you're not really
buying the phone in total.
You're buying part of it and you sort of
financing the rest and they apply that
to your bill. That's why you pay one
price for one a phone. If you know,
when you sign up for x amount of
years, you know, it's kind of slippery.
It's kind of a slippery thing. Um, I
think it's way better to do it this way.
You own your phone done and they
have the best phones. I mean,
it's all like once I'm like,
I'm totally done with the idea of,
uh,
being stuck with one company.
One thing that I,
that I don't like about
the apple thing too.
I don't like getting everything from them.
I don't like that either.
I don't like that. I can't download
stuff like he can't save and files
and stuff like that. With this
thing, you can save files.
Like I could save pdf files.
It's an apple restrictive to a flash too,
right? Don't they have that big
apple doesn't do flash. Yeah. Yeah.
But this thing does everything.
You know, I that I think,
I mean apples, I think the iPhone
is a pretty fucking amazing. Oh,
and if you have an iPhone four or four s
you could bring it over to the tank too.
I phones are pretty fucking amazing.
They're incredibly well designed.
But the difference to them and the android
phones, man, it's really subtle now.
It used to be pretty obvious, but now
it's pretty, God damn subtle. It's a,
it's pretty fucking close and
the distance between the d,
The difference rather between the
experience you get with the larger screen,
that's a big difference.
The difference between the quality
of them is a small difference.
I mean crazy can't deny apples
build quality. It's amazing.
They make amazing phones,
but the differences in the experience
of having a screen that's six inches
versus, or 5.7 inches as opposed
to having a screen it's for,
there's a big difference that
that phone sucks up fat Dick,
if you're trying to watch
a movie. Yes, this is,
you can actually watch videos
clearly and it looks cool. Anyway,
Ting bitches,
Tei and g,
go to rogan.ting.co.com and
save yourself $25 off the um,
off of your first ting
device when you sign up.
So rogan.ting.com and save 25
bucks off your first ting device.
It's an excellent, excellent cell
phone company. The way they work,
you purchase your phone,
get it from Ting,
you receive it in two
to five business days.
Then you activate your device with Ting.
You have the option to select a new
phone number or port an existing one and
tangled,
break your rates up by minutes,
text messages and megabytes and bill you
at the end of the month for what you've
used. Why am I pausing? I'm 98% of people
saved money with Tang. They love it.
So you'll love it too. Uh, we're also
brought to you by on it, o. N n. I.
T if you haven't been to on it for awhile.
We have a lot of new shit
including digestive tech enzymes,
trying to get involved in as many
things that optimize health as possible.
And I'm sure along the way there's going
to be some that I find not worth the
effort and there's going
to be some that I find, uh,
they don't really seem to help. But, uh,
I am a believer in digestive
enzymes. Um, I think that
you get enzymes from food, you know,
and you can get enzymes from, I mean,
from milk,
like raw milk.
It's one of the reasons why raw milk
digests better than pasteurized and
homogenized milk because
it has the enzymes in it.
It's like it's a normal thing to eat
when you're eating milk and it's gone
through pasteurization and what does
it homogenization. Is that what it is?
Cause that was your
homogenization, whatever the
word is, whatever the word is,
where they boil the fuck out of it
and kill everything that's alive.
You're not supposed to eat it like that.
Like when it goes into your system,
your system's like,
what is this fucking
dead shit?
You just threw down the hole and then
you start lifting your cheeks up and cut
and horrible milk farts. Yeah. Dude,
I was by myself last night
and I had cookies in milk.
I just laid some of the worst farts
of my career. Yeah, that's nice.
I didn't yet get any digestive enzymes.
I fucked up Tommy Buns.
Cookies and milk did it? Yeah.
Cookies and milk are not good.
Gluten free or whatever.
Still Milk.
I had Carnegie aside and eggs for
breakfast with a Spanish rice and uh,
all kinds of dead stuff out of me.
It was hard to a dead stuff. He's
seen the Godzilla trailer. Uh,
no. You haven't seen it. Oh wait,
no. Maybe I did. I was a new way.
There's a new one that's just a new one.
Oh, it makes me, I saw the other one paid.
Merrick's Ma Monster Boehner. Hard. Pretty
good. Yeah. It looks pretty bad ass.
There's all kinds of new monsters in
here. Yeah. Speaking of monsters. Yeah,
we have, we have Zombie kettle bells
too. It's the newest thing we have.
If you're like a big walking dead fan
and you're like, you know what, man,
I need to prepare for the invasion.
I need to feel it in my bones.
I'm trying to work it out with one
hour of Zombie. Kettlebells awaits.
What weights do you have?
72 pounds. 54 pounds,
36 pounds and 18 pounds. If you've never
done it before, start with 18 trust me.
You can get a really good workout with
18 and you're like, that's ridiculous.
I'm a fucking savage man. I know you
are. I know you aren't, dude. Trust me.
Get the Keith Weber Extreme
Kettlebell cardio DVD that they sell.
There's one and two that they sell it
on at.com and that cardio workout will
fuck you up. I'm in pretty good shape and
that thing fucks me up with 35 pounds.
What is it credible?
What's the workout?
It's called the extreme
kettle bell cardio workout.
It's not like a bulk thing and you're
not lifting like a lot of weight.
Like I do the, I seriously
do this exercise with 35
pounds, which is pretty light.
You know, I can pick
that up pretty easy. Um,
but when you do it and you know,
you get five minutes in and your lungs
were on fire and your fucking legs are
burning,
you don't,
you can't believe what kind of a workout
you can get with just an 18 pound
kettle bell. How long do you do that
workout for? 40 minutes. Whoa. It's hard.
It's intense. It's brutal. Yeah. My
Heart's killing me at the end of it.
Everything is killing me. My
heart's pounding. I can't breathe.
It's amazing that that's like that.
You could do that with a 35 pound
kettle bell. When I was young,
when I just used to do like weightlifting
stuff like bench press and shit like
that.
I used to think that 35 pounds for policy.
So I wanted to get past that 35 pounds
as quick as possible using the fifties
now like that's what everybody does.
They want to go to 15 hundreds. Yeah. Um,
I think somewhere along the line
you realize how much strength,
I mean especially when it
comes to athletic performance,
how much strength you need and how
much muscular endurance you need.
Muscular endurance is a huge part of
anything athletic and using dude doing 35
pounds. Yeah, you're
going to develop strength,
but you're really going to
develop muscular endurance
and you could build muscle
on bodyweight exercises with a 35 pound
kettle bell and you could have a fucking
rocking sexy body. Tommy ponds
were, I'm trying to do it.
I took my first, uh, kickboxing Muay Thai
guys yesterday. Oh, it's so good for you,
man. Yeah, that's great.
Especially if you go to what Jim?
Um, it's, uh, it's down in
so I could stalk you. Yeah,
I'll tell you later
on a.com. Oh, and,
and it used to code name rogue and
save 10% off any and all supplements.
He bonds.
Is He
bomp bomp bomp bomp oh yeah. Um, this,
uh, Wednesday night where the Ice House,
uh, it's me, Ian Edwards.
I'm Tony Hinchcliffe. A full charge. Yeah,
the full charge map, full Tron, uh,
Lee camp. And I think that's it.
That place is the best. Yeah. It's
amazing. It's going to be fun. Uh, it's,
it's one of the coolest places to
perform in southern California.
I would've gone, I got to have dinner
with my cousin Brian. If you hate,
if you get out of there
and they'd go to bed early,
they're going to be at your house
now. I'm going to be kind
of east side of town. Maybe
fucking cart blanche Tom Bunch anytime
you want. I appreciate that. And um,
December 27th at the Mirage in Vegas,
it's me,
Joey Diaz,
Ari Shaffir,
and Brian Cowen trying to put the ground,
the greatest show in the history of the
universe. So Joey Diaz, Ari Shaffir,
Brian Cowen and me, uh,
all at the Mirage in Vegas.
Can't fucking wait for that. We're
going to have so much fun. Yeah.
That's going to be,
those people going to walk out of there.
They're going to be bleeding
from laughing. That's crazy.
I spent the weekend with Joey.
Oh,
he's the greatest human being that's
ever walked the face of the planet.
Oh my gosh. Cue The music. We'll
talk about your weekend experience.
Try my day. Joe Rogan podcast. Tom,
what'd you guys go? You went with
Joey somewhere? Yeah, and Joey and I,
uh, the Calusa casino in northern
California and then went to hell.
The point is that that's like,
it's an hour from the Sacramento and then
we did a Mcdonald theater and Eugene,
Oregon on Saturday. Wow. Eugene,
Oregon. Must've been fun.
Yeah,
they had snow like that.
A snow storm the night before
and all. We were like, yeah,
it's fucking Oregon. Like they get snow.
Big Deal. We got there and the like,
we haven't had snow in four
years. We were like, oh wow.
Because they didn't plow any roads.
None.
So everything was just caked over iced
over. That part of the real blinding.
I thought it happened all the time there.
Do you remember when they did that in
New York City when it snowed and they
didn't blame him? Plow? No, there was a
big deal. It was a couple of years ago.
It was a couple of years ago.
There was a huge thing where they didn't
budget correctly and they had a big
snow storm and people were trying to get
out there like where the fuck are the
plows? Yeah, it's funny, there's
certain you can tell who's set up,
who's used to snow because of,
because solely because of the road.
It's like when you're in Minneapolis
and they'd be like, you know,
eight inches fell last
night. You're like, Ooh,
I wonder how that'll let you step
outside and you just see, you see black.
Like they paved it immediately.
You don't see any way there.
They're just on top of that shit. And then
you go like clearly when we were like,
oh, you guys never get
snow here because the road,
and then I saw today people
who are at the shows,
I went to their Twitter and their like,
roads are still shit.
Like I haven't done anything
for like three days. It was a,
a video of famous video from Oregon of
these people sliding on this icy road.
Really?
Yeah.
It's a famous video because
I guess they're just
notoriously shitty and allowing
because it doesn't snow very,
they didn't do a fucking thing.
This video is ridiculous.
It's like 10 minutes long of people
just crashing into each other.
Just standing there watching people
come down this road and smash into each
other.
Dude,
the funny thing is they,
the promoter called us a few hours
before the show and she's like, man,
we've been getting a lot of phone
calls of people. Like I can't, I'm not,
I can't drive in this. We're not
gonna make it. She was like a lot,
I don't know how many people are
going to be at your show. I was like,
well how many, you know, there's
nothing we can do about that. Like okay.
Right and then we get there and
there's still like a great turnout.
Everybody who came was a podcast list.
This, Whoa, look how they're
sliding all over the place.
I mean that it's fucking ice. Yeah,
I can't stop his car. Look, look.
It's just going to slide in that
car behind him. This is ridiculous.
Is that important? Oh Shit.
Boom. Nascar's sliding.
They're all sliding.
The whole thing is ice.
That is fucking terrifying. Cause
what to the right? That's water.
Oh No. Yeah Dude. That shit
is absolutely terrified.
Sky Bridges are our real problem.
Bridges for some reason,
because they're not connected to the
earth. That ground freezes super quick.
So if you're in a place and it gets,
it starts getting cold when you
might be in an icy rain situation.
Stay the fuck off of bridges,
guys. Like you fucking, oh my God.
Look at this thing, man. This is crazy.
Look at this thing. Just sliding.
What part of Oregon is this?
It doesn't say I'm Maria.
Portland. Portland. Yeah, you bitches
got to prepare for it. Okay. That's,
this is preposterous. Portland,
Oregon frozen rain is what it is.
You could see on those, uh, like on
that fence when you could see that,
that shit that's sitting there
that looks like snow and snow,
but it's also a lot of frozen rain.
It's like when it gets to be like 32,
just 32 and it was just 33 and (333)
023-0430 two and you get that horrible
fucking frozen rain.
UHMM son Shit.
Yeah. Fuck that noise.
He's still going sideways.
When I was a kid, when I was in high
school, me and my friend John Jewitt,
he was a, my sister's boyfriend.
We were on the roof of the garage.
Me and him just sitting
there drinking beer,
watching cars slide into each other
on our street the best because people
couldn't,
I lived on a hill and a no one,
you couldn't tell that it was a
total black eyes. You couldn't tell.
So people were driving like
normal. Yeah. Then it would
just whew
across from a river and like when it would
start to freeze, like I would get it,
you know, and you're close to the water,
you know, I guess maybe it's colder.
I mean, if that makes any sense. But uh,
the fucking entire street
just was a giant hockey rink.
So we called the cops and the cops came
down the hill and the cops came down the
hill just bang poem.
But they came to investigate.
These guys don't know how to
drive. That's the problem. Yeah.
The whole thing was a hockey rink.
So they got in and just bounced off
the curves this in mass. Whew. Yeah.
Newton Newton. Upper falls. Jesus Christ.
Yeah, it was, it was whore, dude. I
gotta tell you Diaz, first of all,
he got stopped in three different airports
by like eight different people this
weekend. Oh. By throngs of
fans. You're saying fans, TSA
at the airport and they want to
check out her, his balls for weed.
He, first of all, my God,
that is his tolerance is
it's under running. Dude,
I took a quarter of a bite of an
edible. You're brave quarter. Yeah,
I mean the very end of it and 30
minutes later I was just out of my mind.
I mean,
my eyes weren't even open and I could
tell people were looking at me like they
were like, yeah, I mean
you're, you're like, oh, I'm
not hiding this. This is bad.
And he ate of that.
He ate an entire one like that.
And then he's like saying
ridiculous Shit Shit that I,
I feel like I get arrested
for thinking it. Like I don't,
I can't play it back in my head.
I was like, dude, shut the fuck.
Is he saying I cannot, I really can't say
the main thing that he was, I can't, hey,
it would be,
it was not okay to say [inaudible]
have to do with ethnic groups,
racial things.
This one in particular is so awful.
Like I came to spin it. I can't
spend a joke, you know, I have,
and this is one of the things
that I've been on about lately.
I have a real problem when people get
upset at people that say shit that they
don't really mean, but that's awful,
but hilarious. Yeah, I agree. I agree.
Because like look how hard we're laughing.
No, yeah, I get the picture. You guys.
Yeah. I don't even know what he said.
I don't even know what he said to you.
And I'm already laughing.
Just crazy thinking about all the shit
he said to me in the path. Of course.
Of course. Well, he, he's going off
about this thing. I'm standing there,
I look like I'm gonna puke because I'm
laughing so hard because this is in the
airport and he's around people.
He has no give a fuck,
fuck blah, blah, blah. Shut
up dude. He doesn't give a
fuck. And I've, I have tears.
People looking at my, and then he's
like Tsa and uh, this guy, I look in,
the uniform looks over and he's like, you
got to look at this guy. I'm like, dude,
I'm all fucked up. Like
don't bring attention to me
right now. And then that guy,
he's like, Hey Joe Diaz,
I'm a big fan. I'm like,
are you fucking kidding me right now? I
turn around and walk away. I was like,
I'm leaving. It's too high for this.
I walked away, I leave him, I'm like,
I don't want any part of the shit.
And I go,
I buy a magazine that I leave at the
counter. That's how high. I'm like,
I want to get this magazine.
And then I walk away from it and I
remember like 30 minutes later before we
board and I go back and it's sitting
there and I go, that's my magazine ladies.
Like, okay. And I go, I paid for
it already. And she was like,
okay, like go ahead and take that
if you went so out of my mind.
But then, then we walked by, we go
and a guy, a fucking pilot comes by,
you know when they have like,
they're always have the double
look luggage thing right there.
One bag on top of the other,
the pilot bag.
He fucking walks by us and he's
like, Hey Joey Diaz. And I'm like,
are you serious right now? And
he's like, it's my airport.
Everybody calls me to say what I'm like,
really? My airport and then Oregon,
this was in Burbank,
Burbank airport.
We then get stopped in,
we land in Sacramento and
people stop them for pictures.
Then the baggage handler, uh, stops him.
Asked him like 100 weeks.
I hate these fucking questions guys.
Ask Way too many questions. No.
Okay. So we, we leave there.
Well he's super high. Can't off just
having conversations with people.
Then a family stops him.
A lady with kids stops him for a picture.
They all take a picture together. Like
it was nonstop. The best was that, oh,
this is the best part.
So I take the quarter bite right and
I'm completely fucking out of my mind.
He eats an entire one.
We sit down on the plane and he
starts talking to me. I'm like,
shut up man.
Shut the fuck up.
I cannot listen to you right now
cause I'm like shaking. I'm like,
I told him to shut up. Cause you're
laughing. Yes, yes. I'm like,
I can't hear you talk. Shut
up. And he's like, he's like,
he like looks around. He's like,
anyways. And he opens up a second one,
eats the sec and of the thing
I have a quarter bite of,
so he's on eight doses of I'm
and I'm like,
Jesus Christ.
So we go through this flight and every
time he looks at me, like I said, he goes,
oh. And I'm like, dude,
shut the dog and story.
No dunking a cookie. And then he calls
him an hour and a half later. It goes,
welcome to my world mother Fucker,
Dude. Ow, ow, ow. We land,
we land and I, and um, as
we're landing, I was like, man,
I go, dude, I was, I was pretty
fucked up man. And he goes,
and I look at him because
all I'm thinking is like,
I can't believe how much more advanced
you are. The me, you know, it's like,
like, I cannot believe what you mean
tolerance wise. It's like, it's like,
I can't believe I ran a mile
and you just ran 40 miles,
like as crazy as me and we both
finished at the same time and then I go.
So I'm amazed that he's not affected.
I go,
I can't believe how much that fucking me.
He goes,
I almost had three panic
attacks on that flight.
I was like, yes. It made me
so happy that he was awesome,
so fucked up. And He, I was like, Carrie
still goes right back, right back in.
I go, I go, I'm glad it's starting to
wear off. He goes, not for me. I'm fucking
upright.
Yeah. His idea of going deep is
so much deeper than your idea.
He's breaking world records
on a daily basis all the time.
He's at the bottom of the Marianas
trench with a shovel and he's like,
there's got to be a deepest spot.
This is bullshit.
And the first thing he did as we get off
that was like, let's smoke this joint.
I was like, are you talking about,
what are you talking about man?
We're not smoking a joint.
I can take a break.
And he's a maniac.
He's a brainiac. Yeah. Well he just
goes through the whole day like that.
And that's where, you know, people
would step in and say, well,
that boy's got a problem. Yeah. I'll
tell you what he got. But he doesn't,
he gets for a comedian. Yeah. It might
be the best way to live life. Yeah.
Scared on a regular basis and in
betweens. Laughing your dick off. Scared,
laughing your dick off. Scared, laughing
you dick off. Yeah. He, um, uh, he's,
the funny thing is like,
even his
regular cadence,
it's so is out of the norm for other
people that you see people react to them.
It's more fun to even watch people like
at the restaurant next to us react to
him than it is almost to watch him.
Like he's talking and I see them like,
they're like, Jesus. Like
this is like a fucking,
it's like you brought in a pit bull to
have lunch here. You know what I mean?
They've never seen somebody so intense
and animate and saying these crazy things.
It's like you watch them react to Joey.
Right, right, right. Yeah. Yeah. I
know what you mean, man. He's just,
it's just a, they don't come
along that often. No, he's a,
it's a rare thing that's a
there. They're like, well,
who's this guy? Yeah. You know,
like you know guys and you go,
oh I get it.
That guy's like a little bit of this guy.
A little bit of that guy's combination of
Joey's just like, what is
that? Where'd that come from?
You want to kill somebody? You
invite him over for dinner. What?
Oh is his logic,
how to get crimes committed correctly.
And then my favorite thing is
they'll say something and go,
you know what the fuck I'm saying
is I need to just walks away.
I can end on a strong point.
You want to kill somebody,
you invite him over for dinner. Boom. He
walks away. Great sense of timing. Yeah.
Amazing. It's, it's a standup timing that
he uses like in everyday real life. Yeah.
It's like never doing an act.
Yeah. Cause his act, his,
his life and his life is his act. Yeah.
The way he talks his, his act. Totally.
That's like the best
you could ever hope for.
The best you could ever hope for is like
a merging of you and your ability to be
you offstage and onstage. Yeah. I mean,
I mean look at like who everybody or
a lot of people that say it was like,
you know,
total master comedian basically talks
in his voice like Chapelle walks up and
he's like tells you about his day. Yeah.
And that's kind of like the highest form,
right, of being a comment. Cause
you're like, I'm just going to,
this isn't even a thing. I'm
just talking to you. Yeah.
And like Diaz is like a version of that
where like he's just being Diaz. Yeah,
just being Diaz. But he also works
out, it works really hard. He writes,
he does a lot of sets.
Joey does a lot of sets.
He'll go up like four or five times a
week in town in weird places. So yeah.
Travel to Oxnard and shit
and do a set somewhere.
He does a lot of like weird
sets. He does. He gets up a lot.
He was killing it man. Killing him.
I'm sure he was. Man. What is a Eugene,
Oregon like besides hippie and
they don't know how to plow. We,
we got to see so little of it
because of the weather. Like it was,
it was for Real Hotel Gig hotel.
There was no checking anything out.
Right. But the people were awesome. I
mean, I couldn't believe how fun that was.
The most fun. That was the funniest show.
I've had like top three show the year.
Why Fun.
And it was because of that,
whether the only people that
showed up were podcast listeners.
So they listened to Joey's podcasts to
listen to mine and they were just all
fans. So it was like, it was such
a, it was like doing a, you know,
I was like a special event kind of show.
These audiences are so different now.
Oh my God. They're like great hunt
free. I was like, can you get like the,
like the amount of constant you
get? There's nothing but love. Yeah.
Just nice people. Yeah.
It was awesome. Oh,
so it's weird isn't it? Oh
yeah, it's, it's, and it's,
you can see it's changed so much.
Like for me it's changed so much
in the last few years. Yeah.
It's just for everybody. Yeah.
Everybody, all of us. Yeah.
It's changed.
And then the other thing that like we do
now is we do our podcast live and it's
like, it's, it's like a different type
of live performance. Right. You know,
it's so fun to go. Yeah. You have
a totally different thing going on.
You guys have like a live show. Yeah.
It's like a show, you know, it's like, uh,
like uh,
an actual performance.
But your podcast fits that well
because your podcast has a lot of like
reoccurring Skitch sketches or skits.
Calm segments almost.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Betsy,
do you have a bunch of reoccurring things
that you do people look forward to?
They look forward to? So what we try
to do on those live ones is like,
if we know they look forward to it,
we'll try to at least do a couple of
them and it gets the crowds so excited
about it. So it's like
a fun thing. It's like,
it's almost like the equivalent of being
a band and you have a couple of hits,
you know what I mean? Right
there where they, you know,
they liked that song.
So I'm going to play the song at some
point because I know that's why you showed
up, right? Yeah. So yeah,
it's, it's pretty fun, man.
It's changed everything though for for
our standup too. Yeah. It's weird, right?
It's,
it's so crazy.
It's weird that it all happened out of
the Internet to everybody thought they
had to get on TV.
Everybody thought that the way to
get a fan base has to be on TV,
but that's actually the
way to get a fan base.
It doesn't really know you exactly.
Like if you're on a sitcom like
Mike and Molly, Billy Gardell,
very funny guy and he's going to go see
him. Great Guy. Very good guy. Great Guy.
Funny Guy. You know, good for him.
He's got a sitcom, it's great.
But if you want to go see him, you, you,
you're going to see the funny guy that
you see on that show playing a character.
It's not him doing stand up. If you go to
see him doing, stand up, you, you know,
like you know him in a form
of what he does. Right.
But you don't know him right? When they
go to cu, they fucking know you, right?
I mean,
you and I look,
the way we talk right now is the way we
talk when we shut this thing off. Right?
If we shut it off, it would be
real similar. We'd be talking shit.
You tell me what Joey actually said.
That's it be the only difference.
That'd be the only difference in
this conversation. And I think, um,
it's the best way to get a
good crowd or an asshole crowd.
If you're an asshole and you promote
assholishness behavior, I fucking seen it,
man. Have you seen it?
Absolutely. With who?
I can't tell you who does the name
rhymed with. No, but somebody,
it's somebody I don't think you know.
Oh yeah. Yeah. I don't know that dude.
You don't know this guy I've seen, I've
seen crazy. They're real tall. Yeah.
Uh, I've seen, I've seen people
cultivate those and I've also,
the other thing I've seen is
people who have that problem.
You're talking about guys,
and I say it as a problem is
that they might be a certain way.
Then they do this show that's not like
them and you draw a crowd who was like,
I thought you were going to
be this type of humor. Right.
That's the great thing about doing
your like your like it works out great.
I'll tell you it works out great for us.
The guy like tosh where he does his
style of jokes on tosh 0.0 if you're not
responding to what he's doing on
that show, if you don't like that,
you're not going to like a stand up.
But if you like what that
show and you like those jokes,
you're going to love
seeing Daniel Tosh live.
You know it's the smartest way to promote
his live standup is doing that show.
Yes, his wheel house. It's great.
It's fucking funny to, it's great.
It's so funny. He has some good
writers on that show. He does. Yeah.
He's a funny guy. He's a really
funny guy. He's a good guy too, man.
It's a really good guy. It's
nice. It's nice one good
guys. Make it definitely. Oh,
Joey Diaz was talking about Kevin Hart
about what a Great Guy Kevin Hart is
because Joey's in that
new movie with them. Oh,
Robert De Niro and semesters alone,
whatever it is. They're like, yeah, ed.
And they're going to box people. Do people
understand bleeding? Do you understand?
Like how hard it is to stop blood from,
you know,
pouring out of your fucking brain when
you're 80 and you're getting punched in
the head.
Like the idea that movie is more
preposterous than Godzilla. That the idea,
that movie that you're going to live,
is it like former champs for him? Yeah,
a former boxers and they hate each other.
[inaudible] good to go do it one more
time and they're like 80 this is like,
it's so irresponsible to,
yeah, because you know what,
when you're 80 and you take head injuries,
you don't fucking recover from ever.
I mean the suspension of disbelief
involved in watching two old guys beat the
fuck out of each other on TV. This, nobody
would pay for that. It would be sad.
Like if you saw Larry Holmes today
and Larry Holmes fought, you know,
bone crusher Smith today.
I mean it would really be sad to watch
and Larry is at least 15 maybe even 20
years younger than Stallone.
How,
how hurt would these guys be you think
during the fight? What did they just,
they die. They both
die. Sylvester Stallone,
Jews to the Gills pay 72 years
old. It's grapes. Fantastic.
He would murder,
I'm sure Merde de Niro.
Unless the hero God on the sauce as well.
Deniro would have to be on the sauce for
at least a year. Maybe he has, I mean,
so many men are on
testosterone replacement now.
They have commercials for
it on television. Totally.
But I have feeling that the levels that
Sylvester Stallone takes are very high.
Yeah. He's got really
low body fat too. I mean,
we've seen a picture of him walking down
Beverly Hills and you see the veins in
his forearms. No, dude,
it's still from this movie
that looks crazy as shit.
We're selling gay for some of us just
doing fine. Yeah, I'm fine with that.
Give me your flavor.
I met the guy,
I had to interview them for a
spike TV and he couldn't be nicer.
Yeah. Normal like didn't give
a fuck. He's, he's been there,
done that for so fucking long.
That's the reason why he has like a sense
of humor about himself now that maybe
he didn't when he was younger.
Like he's very relaxed man. Yeah.
He's very like talking to him could
not have been like easier and smoother.
Like when you're talking to like
someone and you interview someone,
a lot of the conversation depends on
whether or not that person is relaxed,
whether or not they're comfortable
and if they're not comfortable, man,
the conversations kind of sucked.
It gets hard to do with him.
He's just at ease, laughing
and joking and you know, made,
made some joke about his
mother, his intelligence and
just, he was just funny man.
Yeah. Relaxed. Yeah. That's cool.
But you're not supposed to look like
that when you're seven Nissan. No,
that's ridiculous.
I was like the most notoriously
difficult interview. Well,
he doesn't want to do it right
and he shouldn't. You know,
I think a guy like that as dessert,
he's earned the right to talk to whoever
he wants to talk to and that's it.
And if he doesn't want to be interviewed
about things, I don't need to know him.
He can tell me about him,
what he wants to tell me about him.
I don't need to know him.
And I think
the, the, the beauty of being
an actor, there's probably some,
there's probably some merit and some
extra power in me not knowing him and
knowing that he can go from being the
guy in taxi driver to, you know, being,
you know, fill in the blank. Being
the guy from the godfather to me,
he can morph, he can change who he
is. Being the guy from Cape Fear,
he can morph. And I think if you know
too much of what he is really like,
could you imagine on the flight safe
Deniro had a podcast and on the podcast
every day, who's got his glasses over his
nose either, Ooh, see what we got here.
And he's, she's reading things. And
he's giving you his opinions on things.
I like flowers when actors start doing
that. It puts them in a weird category.
It's true.
And it almost like the ideal way to
be an actor would be to do no press.
Yeah. They do press because
they have to, you know,
a lot of times they're
contractually obligated to do
press to promote movies and
it's all about promoting,
but it does, you know,
the more you know that person,
the harder it is to see them
playing characters. Yeah, sure.
Absolutely. Yeah. Things get weird. Like,
like that was one of the things that
was, that people relished about that. Um,
the audio that was leaked of Christian
Bale screaming at some guy on the set.
Yeah. And a lot of people are like, wow,
he's a fucking asshole. He's an asshole.
And Yeah, he's definitely obviously
very aggressive. But what people,
what people liked about that is they
got to see a human like with no script,
no. Okay, I'm going to go
sit on the couch with Oprah.
No chatting here with David Letterman,
with my legs crossed.
Like I would never do in real life
because none of that. He's like,
for fuck's sake, man.
You're a fucking amateur.
Just screaming at some lighting guy.
Yeah.
There's a Sylvester Stallone
at like 70 Oh my God.
It's not a joke either.
He's like 70. How old is he?
67 that's like 70.
That's amazing. Yeah. Um,
my grandpa didn't look like that
when he was 67 matter of fact,
I think that's around
when he died of old age.
I think my grandpa died of old age,
around 60 sounds 70 but he
didn't look like that. No at all.
No. My grandpa stopped
looking like that. Like 63 six
there's just something
weird about that man.
The idea that you can have a movie where
these two dudes who were in their late
sixties punch each other in the
head and their brains just are fine.
So that was when he was young. It's sexy.
That was the old days. Look, you know,
I could tell that beautiful face.
Very unusual face check.
I'd let them send it in. Yeah, just
for that unusual. Just for that face.
Just that seventies. Look the fucking
jacket on that beautiful hair.
It's feathers. Feathers, not even
hair follicles. Yeah. He's um,
he's the canary in the coal mine
for all who don't want to get old.
That's what you can look like. You might
be a workout animal at 67 too. Huh?
I don't know. I don't know if
I can keep it up. I don't know.
You gotta face the inevitability of
your own demise at some point in time.
I would assume that you can keep
up a certain amount, but um,
our buddy Jimmy just had a fucking
hip replacement. Mark Coleman,
former UFC heavyweight champion.
The first actually UFC heavyweight
champion just had a hip replacement.
The Hammer, the hammer hammer.
Great Guy. Hiphop told me. Yeah,
he told me he was in fucking pain for a
long time and just couldn't do anything
about it.
It's like the,
the amount of work that you have to do
to be like a high level amateur wrestler.
Yeah. Amount of fucking beating that
puts on your body. The amount of stress,
the, the, just the intensity
of those workouts in the, they,
they're all tough as shit. So they all
power through injuries all the time.
And a lot of guys get, you know, really
longterm stuff. Like I know Coleman,
he sat neck surgery as well.
Tito has had a two,
at least two discs fused.
She's, you know, um,
an innate Neda quarry had, uh,
at least two fused as well.
He had it like artificial disc,
putting his lower back.
They create artificial discs
now screw them into the, it's,
it's a fucking tough businessman now.
There's no question that like,
guys like that and professional athletes
are obviously like really doing,
you know, longterm damage where they
have a lot of these replacement. Yeah.
But don't you find that even the amateur
athlete that does certain sports for a
long period of time,
inevitably a percentage of them all
need the same thing too. I mean,
I have an uncle who was,
you know, not a pro athlete,
but a guy who played either
racketball, handball, tennis,
like six days a week. Like one of those
just guys who was really into it, devoted,
you know, that was his whole pro that
he's had two knees and a hip replaced.
And I know,
I know other guys who are
not cause he's like 72 now,
but I know other guys in their sixties,
like he's just like friends of
parents and stuff. They're like,
oh you just had a knee surgery. And
these are just guys who, you know,
played sports. Like they were active,
people didn't do anything. Like, you know,
violent, didn't do a
combat, uh, contact sports.
But they all have things, surgeries,
you know, back, knee, hip.
I feel like it's almost inevitable.
It's almost inevitable if you
keep beating your body up.
If you don't do the proper rehab,
if you don't stretch,
if you don't keep your joints mobile,
that's the focus of shit. A diet.
You got to give your body the
building blocks to, to repair tissue.
You've got to give that tissue time
to repair. A lot of injuries come,
and this is from my personal experience,
the injury that I had on my
neck was from getting hurt.
And just continuing to work out,
like knowing I was hurt and
just just gutting it out.
Just a Jujitsu is so fun.
It's so fun that you don't want
to take too much time off. And when I
would take like two weeks off, like I,
I fucked something up in my neck,
I'd take two weeks off.
Like realistically I
needed several months off.
Like I had an injury and what I really
needed to do was take several months off
and rehab the area and
make sure it's strong,
but I would just heard it again
couple of months later, pop,
ah fuck it hurt again.
And it just kept hurting it.
He kept doing it over and over again
until I finally got an Mri after the worst
one when I started getting numb fingers
and I found out that I had a bulging
disc in my neck,
but instead of getting surgery,
instead of getting my neck cut open,
I started doing what's
called spinal decompression.
I have this like a thing that I,
a harness I attached to my neck and I
put it to a door and I like hang myself
basically. Yeah, I started doing that
and a lot of stretching and then rolfing,
I started getting rolfed, which is fucking
really painful shit. Super painful.
And I started doing this stuff
called pro low ozone therapy.
Like I'm trying like really hard to
make sure that this area is completely
healed up before I do anything crazy
again. It's smart. So then I did that.
And then the most recent
is this re Regina Kine,
Regena kine is this a shit that this
guy doctor Peter Welling developed in
Germany. They take your blood out
and they spin it and the other,
the the heat up the blood
and then it produces,
I guess it produces more red or more
white blood cells and they spin it in a
centrifuge and it makes
us like yellow serum.
That's like one of the most potent
anti inflammatory drugs known to man.
It's made by your own blood and I'm,
I'm doing a terrible job of explaining
the science. I'm sure I butchered it,
but whatever it is, they take this
stuff, they take it out of your blood.
Then they inject it into where you have
injuries or inflammation and people feel
like they haven't felt in 20 years.
It's incredible.
Like he did it to my neck and
only a month ago, five weeks ago,
inject back into your neck.
Is that where a ghost,
they put like in very specific areas
where you have the inflammation,
they inject that,
that serum that's created from your
blood into that area where you have the
inflammation and it heals. It's so
quick. It's like you're in a movie.
Really?
Yeah.
It's like they created some new invention
to relieve yourself of inflammation.
You're basically on, this is
like cutting edge stuff, right?
I mean they're pretty cutting edge.
It's not even approved by the FDA.
You have to pay for it. Pay
for it out of pocket. Yeah.
You have to pay for it out of pocket.
Uh, in Germany they let you do it,
which is why all these athletes
were flying to Germany,
but now they're starting to set up places
in America and they do what's called,
um,
I think off label.
I think that's how I'd describe it off
label in which means like they can't
guarantee anything. They can't tell
you it's going to do anything for you.
The FDA doesn't approve it.
They can't say it's going to help you,
but they can do the procedure.
It's legal if you want to get it done.
Here's all the people that have done it
and here's how it benefited them. Wow.
It fucking works to my neck.
Feels amazing. It feels so loose.
It was like for the longest time. Is this
a video of them doing it? It was they,
they pulled out a eight ounces of blood
out of me today, son. Eight ounces. Yeah.
Lucky am very hot blooded.
I produce blood just sitting here.
I'm producing a lot of blood. They
shoot it, see how they're doing it here.
They put these little holes and then they
have this little thing that sticks in
the hole and they inject the serum
directly into the areas where you have
inflammation and people have had arthritis
and all sorts of different issues,
especially like lower back pain.
They've experienced some
pretty significant benefit
from doing this stuff and it
lasts for years. That's fascinating. Shit,
but you know these dudes that are
in a combat sports, whether it's um,
MMA or even football, it's just kind of
like a combat sport. It's very similar.
Yeah. You're going to get a beating
you, no matter what you do. Yeah.
You met her who you are. Yeah. Peyton
manning actually had this shit done,
had it done to his neck. His
neck was fucked up. Yeah. Yeah.
Probably just like mine. Yeah, but
now he's playing again. It's crazy.
He's playing so well. It's
because of this shit, man. Yeah.
It's because of this Regina con.
This is just step one.
This motherfucker in Germany is a year
away from developing a shot that makes
your body kickstarted to
production of Collagen,
which means your wrinkles will go away.
Really always kind of look odd is
fuck who they were in it. Right?
They're going to watch out for that too.
Oh ladies are going to want some dicks
on how many you imagine if your next door
neighbor was like this old lady who
was really hot at one point in time and
lived for it and then it all fell apart
and then she's by herself and alone and
she starts getting them shots
and then within like a year,
she's like a hot mill,
a hot 40 year old and you're like,
what the hell is going on?
Can I know some flower flirt and with Ya,
you catch her out in the morning.
She's doing exercises and she's
jogging on the front lawn.
She can work out again. Oh, what
the fuck is going on next door?
It's peaches going back in time.
She's eating babies. She must be band.
He didn't know any better. You would
think she's a witch. Of course.
If all the sudden within a year
she looked like a hot 40 year old,
give me that baby. I wonder if
that's possible. It's got to be,
they're going to do it.
If you eat,
if you could send a video through
the fucking sky instantaneously,
you can take a video.
You could send it to me from Canada
and I would get it within a couple of
seconds. Yeah, that's ridiculous.
That's possibly get that.
That's your neighbor bro. Yeah. Look
at that. And you're like ice cube.
Ice Cubes are rapey.
They're very raping.
I'm not done.
That was there.
Yeah, just like that.
Just like that. Yeah.
If that I get to be lady Tucker right
there and wait in that scenario. No,
you get to be Tommy buns. Okay. I
think you'd have a better response.
But Louis' dirty bitch.
Nothing.
Yeah, that's what we would, uh, that's
what we'd be dealing with everywhere.
All across the world.
A lot more fucking going on.
A lot more fucking the old guys
who become studs to, sure. Guys,
within a couple of years we'll start
looking like Stallone does now.
You imagine like successful guys like
guys who were real power brokers,
Murdock becomes the hawk.
Oh my God.
Literally looks like the Hulk and just
dropping dick internationally the door
with a custom suit on because
his neck is 37 inches wide.
These heads enormous and square,
and this is Rupert Murdoch becomes
like literally like Juggernaut. Yeah,
it becomes the hawk.
If someone came along and they did have
some sort of a genetic fix like you,
and especially if you're an old man,
if you're like 80 years old and they say
to you, well, we can give you this shot,
they will turn you into the shape.
You will.
You will more if you're going to eat
all day long because you're going to be
hungry constantly.
But if you give yourself the
required amount of calories to grow,
you're going to be this
and like a couple months,
you just fucking keep growing
old guys.
Be All all over it, man.
No question you did.
It just becomes like a Quaker oats box.
Just one of those big extra thick Quaker
oats boxes. I think you know what?
You'd be so charged up
and so sexually recharged.
You just be leaking Tj's all day.
Every week.
You'd have to put a little
like a little receiver,
a little receptacle at
the end of your cock.
You'd have to tie a very sturdy
balloon on the end of your tick.
Absolute tape it down.
Otherwise it just be shooting loads
in your pants all day and you just go.
You just literally have to drop them.
I think that Shit's inevitable.
They're doing things right now that
are the building blocks of creating
superheroes. Like they have this, um,
this project where they're
trying to combine spider
silk with a, with human skin.
They're trying to make this synthetic skin
that would be like a replacement skin,
like burn people,
burn burn victims and you know,
and maybe people who just really wanted
to redo their whole body one day. Really?
Look, man, they're replacing hips. Okay.
What does a hip, a hip hippos. A joint.
They saw your fucking joint off
when you see a hip replacement.
It's some dark shit. Have you ever
watched it online? No. No, let's do it.
Let's watch a hip replacement.
It's rough.
They saw the end of your femur off son
and they screw this fucking bolt in
place. It's gnarly. I all
that shit. Surgery is gnarly.
Surgery is gnarly, but replacements of
joints, especially seeing a faceless,
but well yeah, that's Gnarley or
a nose job. Oh, that's not what,
I didn't see what my nose looks like.
But you saw some of the bloody boogers
after I had my nose fixed. I saw you,
remember I showed you those,
you almost threw up one of the point
you had when you were putting that water
pick up your nose. Yeah. And it was
flushing stuff out. Yeah. Let's, um,
maybe we shouldn't watch this,
so it looks like a ham.
They open you up and then they,
they cut off the end of your leg and
then attach this artificial joint.
Who was the first guy to make
a fucking artificial hip?
Cause that guy took a goddamn chance.
He really, he really, all right.
We're going in and I mean,
how many people,
how much did his hips suck? Where he was
like, cut my fucking leg off. Like, yeah,
the first guy. Yeah. Well, my
friend who had it done in New York,
according to our friend Brian Cowen,
he was um,
he was walking so bad like he,
one leg would bend and the other
leg he would just sort of swing.
He would swing it over.
He would keep it attached to his body and
like sorta swing his body sideways and
that's how he moved forward. He didn't use
his hip. This a fighter guy? No, no, no.
He put just played basketball
on a concrete in New York City,
played a lot of basketball and
he was like 50. Now is legacy.
There's another one like,
have you seen like the way some of
these old basketball players walk?
Holy Shit ever. Really
big too. They're monsters.
You think when you're talking
about a seven foot human,
the amount of like torque that goes
on to all these different joints,
the ankles and the knees and the hips.
There's so much pressure because you're
dealing with is extremely long lever.
It's one of the reasons why
like long legged and long
armed guys punched so hard.
It's also one of the reasons why
they're so good at submissions.
They have like extra leverage because
they're, their limbs are literally longer.
They have more of a better
fulcrum and that makes sense.
But it also puts tremendous
pressure on your joints because the,
have you ever seen Phil Jackson Walk in
recent years? Yeah. Oh my God. You know,
he was a player for a lot of years.
His walk is the most like it's,
you see the pain when you're watching,
you're like, that guy's walking in pain.
Well, when I was a kid I worked
at the Boston Athletic Club,
which is a health club in South
Boston. Nice place. And uh,
people would come in there
and play racquetball lot
and Bobby or he used to come
in there all the time. Oh yeah. One of
the greatest hockey players of all time,
all time. And when I was
there, I was about 19 and a,
I don't know how old Bobby was.
He was probably about my age.
Now I'm 46 and he couldn't walk.
Ban. Really? Oh Man. I mean,
not only could he not walk, he has his
sides of his legs were cut open like fish,
like the,
the scars that they put on his legs.
Like he's probably older than me.
He's probably now that I think about it,
he was probably older than me then. I bet
he was probably in his fifties but the,
the old way of doing it,
they would just open you up like a fish
and then they would take chunks of your
leg,
like your hamstring and it's screw them
in place and try to replace ligaments
with them.
And they would last for a little while
and then they blow out so they'd have to
fucking stitch you up again and Bobby or
had something insane like 17 surgeries.
So when he walked, man he couldn't,
he literally couldn't bend his knees.
So he would like kind of hop and move is
like for her to put it down and lift up
and move is like forward to put it down.
And there was a machine called
a versa climber, a verse,
a Columbia ever seen one of those things,
great cardio machine.
Get on there and you fucking go crazy
with this thing. He couldn't get on it.
We used to have to help him on it. We
used to have to help him lift his leg up.
And when you looked at them,
if you looked at his face,
looked like a real healthy guy. He
wasn't out of shape. He wasn't, you know,
overweight. His just, his legs were
gone is so fucking brutal though.
Oh rain. It's, think about
it. You're sliding around
and you're on ice. Yeah. Knees are
going every fucking which way. You know,
you like lamb 40 miles an
hour. Yeah. Yeah. It's crazy.
Yeah. And once your knees go,
you know they're going to keep going.
Yeah.
I know that Dick [inaudible] hasn't been
able to like walk normal for so long
while, and he's, you know, he's
probably like 70 or something now,
but he hasn't been walking normal
in 15 years. Plus, you know,
because those guys,
guys like Bobby or Mike Ditka played,
you know so long ago that they would just,
they really didn't do the most
important thing when you're hurt,
which is like take time off. It was
like nobody did back then fucking play.
Yeah. You know, obviously
that's especially relevant
when it comes to concussions.
Oh yeah.
Cause they're really just starting to
kind of get a grasp on that within the
last 10 years. So it's like what kind of
regulations that she just played. Yes,
sure. Especially if you were
everywhere. Absolutely. Absolutely.
Like toughen up pussy. Toughen
up. Yeah. And they would,
and they were doing and it
was so not about being tough.
Those guys are submitting,
those guys should have been not having
any contact for weeks or months.
Yeah. They were just rocking
their brain for week after week.
Probably multiple concussions in
the same week. Yeah, man. Crazy.
All these guys that keep dying and
shooting themselves in the heart so that
people can examine their brain. Just
that alone. It's like God, it's so dark.
Yeah.
Early onset Alzheimer's dementia,
and they're like 45 50 yeah.
I think they're very close to being able
to figure out how to regenerate human
tissue and they're, I think they're going
to be able to turn back the clock. Yeah.
I think within a hundred years
it's going to be, I mean,
you and I might not see it,
but I think they're very
close to being able to create,
literally create superheroes.
If you think about,
look what people have accomplished in
such a short amount of time and what they
can do now as far as like gene therapy
and using stem cells to heal things like
bas Rutten went down to another
country to get a stem cell treatment,
some South American country. We've got
some stem cell treatment because he,
he's had like significant atrophy of his
arm because of a pinched nerve in his
neck. He had like some serious neck
injuries from fighting a little bit,
but really from stunt work that he did
after fighting, really fell on his neck,
fucked himself up bad. He's got
his neck fused, his discs were bad,
so they cause this out and fuse his neck
and there was a lot of problems with it.
So he went and got this stem cell thing
and then all of a sudden he's feeling
fucking fantastic. He's talking about
how great he feels. Really. Yeah,
it feels great.
He's talking about was his body's growing.
He's been doing all this exercise
again for the first time,
like really intense exercise and he's
like not fitting into a suits anymore.
It's got to change the,
the,
the collars and the suits because
he can work out again. Wow. Yeah.
You have to imagine that like if they
master that, all that genetic stuff,
that one of those mad
scientist is going to be like,
let's build the best fighter ever.
Let's build
the best basketball player ever.
Like genetically make somebody like that.
You know what I mean? Like, and
people will abuse that for sure.
People got to do it for their kids.
Of course they're kids are
going to be superheroes. Yeah.
It's gotta be weird, man.
I'm telling you,
we're,
we're probably a hundred years away from
a time where genetic improvements are
like cell phones. Everybody
has it just, we just have it.
It'll be real expensive at first and only
the elite. We'll be able to afford it.
And then as time goes on, yeah, it'd
be more and more common and prevalent.
Just like a cell phone.
And then you got to wonder what will be
the common problem associated with doing
it because there's always a hangup to
something like that, you know? Well,
there's probably going to be people
that try to almost die and then bring
themselves back and think it's funny
and they'll do it on youtube, right?
You know,
they'll have friends shoot them with
like 50 millimeter guns here and then
they'll uh, regenerate, regenerate.
How awesome was that fucking shrink
back up and he'll just like wolverine.
That's a,
yeah,
we're going to have a lot of problems
when it comes to technology and the next
hundred years or so in
the real problem is,
will it ever get to a point where the
amount of power that people have does,
it doesn't measure up with the amount of
responsibility they have and the amount
of respect they have for that power.
That's kind of where we're at right now
when it comes to being able to contact
people on Youtube.
Like if you find someone puts a video
up expressing their opinion and you're
like, you fucking ugly con,
I want to eat you alive.
And people that say crazy
shit like that on youtube,
like they shouldn't have the ability to
just communicate with people like that.
It shouldn't have the ability to just,
they're abusing and incredible power
you to just instantaneously communicate
with someone anonymously.
Well that's the thing is you should
be able to do it with accountability.
But even when the accountability,
like what kind of accountability,
if I can't see you and you, no one's
looking at you and know what's going man,
you're a piece of shit. You know, if
you say something to someone in person,
like the way people say
something on Youtube,
like say if you're in the lobby of a
hotel and you see some guy just say some
fucking horrible thing to a another
guy there, you would go like, Whoa,
that guy's an asshole.
But if that happens to you online,
if some guy, some guy just sends
you something horrible online,
you don't see him and I don't see him
and nobody knows who this guy is and he's
XP 49 k on Youtube or whatever his,
his youtube handle is.
He doesn't feel that. He doesn't feel
the repercussions of that. You know?
It's almost like you have
this incredible ability,
but you don't have any responsibility
that comes along with it.
You don't have any ethics that go along
with it because you don't respect it.
You didn't develop it yourself. They
just got online. You know? It's like,
it's so easy to just get online.
You know?
You don't even have to have your
own computer because your computer,
you get online and remember you're
going to Carroll full queue.
You can do anything you want that,
that,
that access is so common
that people who don't,
you know, they probably are too
stupid for anything that powerful.
That's the same argument about guns.
It's the same argument about a lot of
different things and dangerous thing is
those people are also unhappy. Right?
And that's why they're doing so.
If you're that unhappy, but now your
power is genetic mutation, you know,
it's a little different than than
saying, go fuck yourself. Well,
you know what it is
ultimately all of that,
and I'm not saying that it's not the
people's responsibility who do it,
but ultimately all shit
behavior is a real risk.
The one of the real results of it is
the fact that we don't address that as a
culture,
as being a major issue,
that we don't address it as
a culture that we don't have.
It reinforced in the kids'
heads at an early age,
that the way to get by in life is to be
as nice to as many people as possible
and a lot of times when you have bad
feelings and you feel bad or there's anger
or jealousy,
oftentimes this can be because you need
to fix your own life oftentimes and you
need to get your own life in order where
you don't feel jealous about someone or
you don't feel anger for something
that someone has that you want,
like use it as fuel to fix your life.
Nobody teaches do that.
Nobody tells you that in school.
It never gets brought up.
And then we also never deal with poor
people as if they're just people that are
a part of our community that have a
way worse position in life than we do.
And we need to fix that because it's
the lowest ring. A rung of the chain.
We would just crawl. Yeah, got
the chance on wrong, wrong,
but rung sounds like a ladder, like rung
on the ladder, rung of a chain link, link,
link of a chain, but the lowest, okay.
Rung of the ladder that you
know, that's us. That's us.
Just because we don't talk to them.
It's still us.
Don't they live like a mile from us?
Well then that's us, but we ignore them.
It's easier to ignore him.
But as a society,
that should be like one of the first
things that a government takes care of.
Extreme poverty, extreme poverty and
children growing up in extreme poverty.
That's the big one.
Not just extreme poverty.
If you're a fucking guy and you're 35
years old and you decide you just love
math and you're just gonna mess
it up and fucking do, but that's,
that's your decision. If you went from
being a lawyer to be in a meth head.
I mean,
I'm not saying it's not in part based
on how fucked up your childhood was.
It probably was, but you might
be too far to fix. But Kid, yeah,
you can fix kids, man. Catch
him early and it said so.
It's so bad for everyone when you have
that level of poverty because you have
resentment. And of course a lot of
crime is resentment. It's not just need,
it's resentment and
need to give everything.
I have nothing and no morals
because everybody around
you is doing whatever they
have to do to get by.
You're just dealing in an environment
where you're dealing with a lot of people
in and out of jail.
So depressing and you don't see
any examples of how to get out.
And there's so many people to like, people
always presume, a lot of people in, in,
in, in the United States presume
that extreme poverty is, you know,
the favelas
in Brazil,
which it is,
but they don't realize that
there is extreme poverty
in this country and they're
strict poverty in Los Angeles. Sure
you can go to one economy in the world.
We have a lot of extreme poverty.
Yeah. And I don't know, I mean, look,
I'm not saying that people don't have to
pull themselves up by their bootstraps,
that people don't have to work hard
in order to be successful. They do.
Absolutely.
But you can't tell me that.
Like me growing up in Newton upper
falls and some poor fucking kid who is
growing up in the worst area of Compton
and his mom's a crack head and his, uh,
his dad is nonexistent and
everyone he knows is in,
in and out of jail and they
have guns everywhere is,
and people die around them all the time.
That's a reality that we don't have to
deal with it I never had to deal with.
But there's people growing up in that
reality that if they had options of
something to look forward to,
it can enhance how they develop.
They don't think about that.
It's the weirdest thing.
It's the weirdest thing about like the
money that gets dedicated in this society,
like where it goes.
The fact that we put so much fucking
money into a war and so little money into
making sure that we have a good supply
of people who are bad motherfuckers,
people who can get their shit together,
people who can contribute to society,
people who were people
who are contributors.
The other thing is the percentage of
people who make up the portion of income
like that.
You have so many,
so few ultra rich that make up
such a huge amount of the income.
So you have basically,
you know this,
this person is 5% you know people always
talk about the was the the the top two
or whatever labor centers, the
one percenters. But like you know,
you have like 5% in the United States
that might make up 30 some percent of of
the, of all the income and hold an
even bigger percentage of the wealth.
You have a very small percentage of people
controlling a whole hell of a lot of
money. That's why it's a, at least on
some level, it's so it's good that,
but like the gates started that giving
pledge where they basically try to get
the world's billionaires to sign up
to give away 95% of their net worth.
But you know,
by the time they die,
so people that are worth
five and 10 and $20 billion,
we'll at least not hold on to that.
They'll give it away.
Because if you, the thing about
growing up in that environment,
if you grow up and your,
you know, your dad makes,
he dad has $100 billion. What, what? Yeah,
so you just get a trust and you don't ever
have to work ever even met those guys.
Sure. That's just some sad
motherfuckers. They always are.
There's some sad motherfuckers.
I knew this dude,
he had a trust and then a backup trust
and he went through both of them and now
he has a job. Yeah. He,
he millions, I believe.
30 something million dollars on real
estate development that didn't go through.
And then he had a backup
trust and that went away too.
And then his parents finally
just, they said, get a job bitch,
and he's like 50 and he's like
finally in like the workforce.
She 50 they cut him loose after just
going through all of his buddies.
He's the weakest man. Like I think one
of the weakest men have ever been around.
Not Surprising. She says no
character, no ability to,
and he even said it.
He was talking to my friend about
her kids and he said if I can,
if I could give any piece of
advice and what not to do,
never let them think that they don't
have to work. You never let them think.
They don't have to work
the, you're a lottery
winner. Yeah. That's the,
the only difference is you won your
lottery the moment you were born.
But isn't it possible to win the lottery
and keep it together? Where signage,
very rare. It's very rare. It's possible.
And I'm sure there's
people who have done it,
but there's more stories about how this
guy fucking fucked everything up as soon
as he won the lottery than there
are. Wow. This guy, you know,
live the fairytale life
after he won the lottery.
I think some of it has to do with
the amount you win. You know,
you can win a lottery. You could win $1
million, you can win two, five $6 million.
When you start talking about somebody
that was making 35,000 a year in the
factory and you get 102
hundred $300 million,
I mean there's nothing
to prepare you for that.
There's nothing to prepare
you for that and the,
the type of attention you're
going to get from that,
the people that are going to come
into your life, it's overwhelming.
Why they're not ready for it.
It'd be different if like you won $100
million because you've achieved success
on your own. You know, you
know, it's, it's still going
to be a difference for you.
But I think having a foundation of like
a career that you've taken on and earn
drone,
you know,
you earn what you've gotten to
have this boost would be different.
I think when you haven't had that level
of success and you get something like,
you know, a nine figure check, I think
it's really hard to keep it together.
There's more stories about disaster and
there are about keeping it together.
When you talk about those big, the
the, what are the big ones called?
They're like the mega millions
powerball, right? Yeah.
If somebody just won a nut,
like over three three
53 55 so much though,
what did they pay them off? They're like,
you have options. You can get options.
Here's the,
if you are not 80 you should
always take no the opposite.
Yeah,
the 20 year,
because you're essentially on
salary for the next 2025 years,
so if you want $100 million,
right?
You're going to get 20 payments over the
course of a t to add up to that amount.
You're gonna have to pay taxes,
but you're going to get your full amount.
The other option they do is they
go, all right, it's 355 million.
You could take that over 20 years or we'll
give you like 158 million right now and
then people go, I'll take the lumps.
It's more, you know, they was
all the money then. Right,
but unless you're about to die,
like why wouldn't you just allow
yourself to earn like what's,
maybe you would be worried that they
would go under continue to pay you. Yeah,
I guess they that that is probably the
worry that's not going to fucking happen,
but what you really trust that someone's
going to stay alive or a business is
going to stay alive for 25
years or whatever it is.
They would still be obligated
to make that payment.
What I'm saying is like if they
go under the state lottery,
I don't think it goes under.
What if it did it in Detroit?
What have you bought
the lottery in Detroit?
I still think that we ain't got no money.
I still think you'd,
you'd still get your money? I think
so. I do. I don't think there's,
I don't think there's such thing as them.
I say take them on and take that lumps.
Asked it in a good business, Tom, we
buns. I think if it's a family restaurant,
I would definitely do that. The 25 year
payout, how much you think you would get.
Okay, let's see if you win the lottery
and you get $350 million, right?
So what's the yearly
payout on 355 million?
I would say they'd probably
do it over 25 years right now.
So let's see. Um, let's say,
let's say you're getting
three 55 over 25 years,
that's 14 million a year,
man.
What if you want to buy
something that's more than 50?
The thing is you can get whatever you
want. Once they like you have that,
they know who you are and they
see like there's no way. And like,
what the fuck are your plans, man? Are
you opening the fucking the new St Regis?
Like why you don't need you? You were
doing your shit for whatever, 50 grand,
you're fine. You have 14 million a
year for the next quarter century.
You've got to change your phone number
and move immediately. Oh my God,
you have the amount of people
that are going to hit you up.
Just give me a million.
You could just give me a million.
You still have all that money all
the time. Come on dude. You friends,
14 million a year. You can't give me
a million a year. And you have to say,
imagine people are going to ask
you to give them $1 million a year.
Do you get 14 million a year? Give
me 1 million a year. Come on man.
You got to be like, you know
whether it's a really good argument,
but I'm going to have to say
no like you make a good point.
What would you do if Matt full
tron one are you good? Play Tommy,
you won $300 million. You can't give
me a million a year. I love you man.
But nothing. You give them nothing. Now
I probably would give. Yeah, I would,
but I don't think you could let people
dictate the terms and how much you have
to give. Whatever you
want to give. You know?
It's weird when someone starts
asking you from a good friend.
I wanted to give him a weird number.
You know, what would you give them?
138 216,000 yeah,
but that's it.
You make 300 million, he gets to
give you a hundred grand. All right,
well I mean Christmas was coming up.
It might give you a bonus.
Would you start a business
that much money? I think. Um,
why would you,
what do you need to make more money?
Why would you start a business
so you could lose some of it? No,
I think the first thing I would do is move
like to the air,
like the exact whatever area.
Neighborhood Home I desire the
most that way. Would that be,
I don't know. Maybe Hawaii. Hawaii, maybe.
I didn't have to travel
to see your friends.
The problem a wise it's five hours away
by plane. I know, but I got the jet now.
Just hop on the jet.
It takes five hours in a plane.
If you live five hours drive
from somewhere, what's five?
How annoying would that be? I know, but
I mean, come on man, I'm sending my jet.
Are you going to be a real, it's a
really nice, okay. How about this?
How about I live in the mountains.
Five hours drive up the top of a mountain.
How often are you going to visit me?
But can I have a second home in Hawaii?
Yes. You could have a second home in
Hawaii, but where are you going to live?
Primary residence. That's a good
question. Let me give up on Hollywood.
I mean I think the motivation
here anymore. Well yeah,
I mean but I mean cause you can
just stand up from anywhere.
If I started doing standup he wouldn't
eat their fucking whore money. Yeah,
there God damn devil do whatever I want.
That's a great, that's a great actual,
it's just where do you want to live
the most? Where would it be? Um,
I still love California.
Maybe.
Maybe either summer beach. I
like the beaches. So maybe Santa,
Barbara's Nice Santa Barbara. Maybe look
more relaxed, less people. Beach Front,
Laguna beach kind of thing. Newport
that area. That's kind of Nice so far.
Um, Santa Barbara is beautiful.
But then I also love, I mean fuck,
I mean if you have $350
million, you probably buy
your houses wherever you want.
Buy a house in Seattle and New York
where you decided to live. Definitely.
Look at you. You love cows. I Love
California. Do you represent? Yeah.
Do you wear like an la hat fucking
heart? People know you represent. Yeah,
it's fun. I love it. I would defend it.
What people live in shitty places and
they have the nerve to shit on where we
live. It's, it's unbelievable.
You do these fucking dog shit towns
and they're like, you live in La.
I'd never want to go there. I'm
like, clearly you have shit taste.
I'm here because they're paying me.
I can't wait to get the fuck out.
So you stay man, stay here. We
don't need you at all. Well,
people's ideas of California being bad
or never visited half the time they're
like, it's their idea of what California
is. That it's all Kanye west out here.
It's like a hundred million Kanye West.
Yeah.
But he's yelling and I'm the greatest
ever. And then Christina has the best,
the best, uh, a story
of a, it was a baggage,
a baggage handler at the
airport in Detroit and he's
putting the bag tag on her
bag and it says lax, like you live in
La. And she's like, yeah. He's like,
I don't want any part of that
shit. She was like, you're fucking,
you're putting tags on bags and Detroit.
You don't want to check out la.
Like what the fuck is your
problem? And he like, well,
it's all that celebrity shit.
That's the other thing is they go,
the city is red carpet.
Like they think that it's like,
and they think that because you live in
La, let's say, and you're not a celebrity,
they're like, you must be obsessed
with celebrity culture. Yeah.
That's the perception. Like, Oh,
you're out there chasing celebrities.
Like what are you talking about man?
Yeah.
I've heard guys also say ridiculous
shit. Like, you know, you,
you couldn't ever meet
a girl out here man,
because a girls just want to
be famous dudes in La. Yeah.
How many famous people do you think there
are just regular guys get laid to out
here? Oh, for sure. What are you talking
about? Like what, what's this based on?
What studies did you, the funny thing
too is for people that don't live here,
even like whether you're a performer,
whether you're working in any type
of the entertainment business at all,
for the most part when you're in
La and people spot celebrities,
nobody gives a shit.
It's the opposite of outside of La.
Like people see celebrities at most
that I've ever seen is people are like,
how's it going man? Big Fan. Like
nobody, people mind their business in La.
It's a big difference between that and
a place where they don't get to see
somebody who is on TV and a regular basis.
Yeah. Becomes passe on here. Like, oh,
there's that guy. Yeah. Which is probably
better, you know? Sure. Definitely better.
Yeah.
You stand out less.
And I totally feel like
the, um, the Cliche,
what weather conversation
that we all have is, it's,
you know, when people are like,
it's overdone, it's underdone, it's,
it's not spoken about enough.
Whether it's everything.
Don't act like having great weather isn't
one of the greatest perks of where you
live or, or the worst part of where you
live. It's w we were talking about that.
Like everybody talk. Yeah, it's
cause it's fucking awesome here.
It's amazing and it's amazing about 96%
of the time and we're going to act like
that doesn't play a huge part and why
this place is great. Of course it is, man.
It does. But I gotta be honest, I like
it when it rains here as it rains.
So rarely I liked, I liked
that it mixes up. It's fun.
Of course you'd like to change,
but the fact that like there are people
suffering for not a day or a week,
months and months of the year and you
have the fucking top down in your car.
Like it's not really something that
you can ignore. It's pretty fantastic.
And it's sunny, sunny, not just nice out.
Like temperature wise you get sun and
you feel it and it feels good. Oh yeah.
And there's the ocean with
fucking sailboat going by
what a nice day it is today.
Okay. Yeah, it sucks. Everything sucks.
I think for a lot of people
that say la socks, there's,
there's a bunch of factors. The
traffic is a big one. The fake,
uh, fakeness, fake
communication that you get here,
the fake people.
You get a lot of fake shit here as
opposed to like what you get in the east
coast, you get you, you get
more authenticity I think,
on a,
in,
in places where people have to deal with
weather and people don't deal as much
with actors. Yeah. It's part of the,
it's one of the downsides of this area,
but it's not enough of a downside
that it makes it suck. Right.
The traffic is enough. That makes sense.
But can I say one thing about traffic?
Traffic here is terrible. Yeah.
New York City, Washington, DC,
Atlanta, Miami, Houston, all these
cities have absolutely disastrous rush
hours and traffic all the fucking time.
If you want to live in
a big metropolitan area,
it's just one of the things
that comes with it. Yeah.
If you want to try to drive from Long
Island into Manhattan, Oh my God.
You want to try and do it in the morning.
Get to word luck dude.
Good luck with that one. So I couldn't
believe it. I couldn't believe the line.
I was like this is,
I was staying in Long Island and driving
into New York for something while ago.
Yeah. And uh, I remember
being on the highway going,
if I had to do this every day I
probably go fucking crazy. Yeah.
Cause it was hours and it's
because of the fucking toll too.
That's another level of bullshit that you
have to deal with in New York that you
don't have to deal with here. Everywhere
you go fucking costs you money. Yeah.
Everywhere, every fucking
bridge. The turnpike, Turnpike,
you got to stop all the time
he stopped and he got to pay.
Aren't those fees now like
create like a deal money,
14 bucks mean that like that's not
chairmen to to drive over a bridge.
Fuck you back and forth. Bridget was
paid for a long ass time ago too.
Yeah that's, that's pretty nuts bin
and then dammit. But I will say this,
my favorite part of the country is like
people wise is definitely the Midwest.
I love people in Wisconsin,
Minnesota,
Ohio and I love those people. They're
really authentic. They're nice people.
The salt of the earth.
And I think that's also because they
don't have to deal with show business.
They don't have to deal
with show business.
They have less stress cause there's not
as much traffic and they have character
because they have to deal with fucking
country weather all the time. Yeah.
Is something about being
happy and you know,
dealing with a little bit of struggle.
I don't think you can get there.
Like I think growing up in California
is like winning the lottery.
I think what you're dealing with is like
an earned respect for the weather here.
Because you're from Cincinnati
and you live in Florida.
You lived in a bunch of
places where it sucks. Right?
And then you come here and you're
like, oh wait a minute. Did you do,
what are you talking about?
This place is perfect,
but one of the reasons why
you're interesting is because
you didn't grow up here.
Oh, right, right, right. Yeah.
So it's great to come here once you're a
developed human. I agree. I agree. And I,
I do think the other thing too about,
the reason I get defensive about like,
you know,
California,
southern California is the amount of
people who go out of their way to tell you
that they like, we weren't even talking
about that dude. You know what I mean?
Like, oh, could I ask you? And
they're like, yeah, you know,
they think it's all the cadet
cardiacs yeah, I know. It's just fun.
That was all city is keeping up
with the Kardashians. Please.
There's a lot of people here, man. A
lot of good people though. Giant number.
You know, when you think about
20 million plus Mexicans,
what does that really boil out to do?
They didn't even have any idea
how many illegal aliens are here.
I don't think we have a real idea. I mean,
how could they? They're illegal aliens.
Yeah. It's like trying to like figure
out how many deer or in a patch of land.
Our state has about 40 million people.
20 million. That's pretty crazy.
And how many of those people do you
think are illegal? Mexicans? Um,
probably, um, around
15. So you don't have,
fuck, that is man, that those
people can never go to college,
can never get a driver's license,
can never vote, can never,
but they live here with their basically
American or pretend they're not American
and like you're not really American.
No, no, no. You didn't do it right.
He didn't do it the way we say you got
to do it, but they've been here for 20,
30 years, but don't, they can't actually
go and get a driver's license. Right.
Can you just go in and
get that without even,
I don't think you can for
paperwork. I think, uh, the
terminator stopped that Shit.
Really? They were going to do that.
But uh, I think he stepped in.
That'll be the next California,
even though it's already
part of the conversation.
That'll be the next huge thing is going
to be immigration reform. Well, you know,
you're not going to stop people from
driving by not by telling them they can't
have a driver's license. You're just going
to create a bunch of illegal drivers.
They're grown adults. If they have
a job and they save up some money,
they get a car by hook or by Crook,
they figured out how to get it on the
road and then they drive around because
this is what they've got to do and when
you arrest them and you take the car
away,
you're just stealing from them.
What you really should do is figure out
a way to make them be a paying part of
the culture. Right? The other
problem is they'll, the,
the big thing that people don't talk
about with illegal aliens is they're not
paying taxes. Because if you're getting
paid in cash and you think about that,
what are the odds that people that are
getting paid in cash or paying the proper
amount, oh, please. You know, he,
he catch some guy and he's a a day worker,
right?
He's working on construction sites
and they're paying them cash. Yeah.
That guy's not going to report any in that
endeavor. And you know, you say, well,
Hey,
he shouldn't have to pay taxes.
He doesn't make much money in the first
place. Oh well, if that's our attitude,
then we better go to those fucking people
working at Mcdonald's cause they're
getting robbed.
Someone's taken from their paycheck.
They have to give to solve security.
Everybody does. Now there's,
there's bill yet many billions unaccounted
for a count of four. That would be,
and I'm not saying that it shouldn't be
at least difficult to become a citizen.
I think you should speak a little bit
of English, at least a little bit.
Make an effort. You should have no
violent criminal history, you know,
and whatever other crimes you've done,
it should be really decided whether or
not we want to include you in our culture.
And if they're not included their culture,
we get rid of them.
This weird thing we do well, we just
sort of tolerate them. You know,
we should let him be Americans that every
American has. God Damn immigrant. Yeah.
Every one of them. Oh, I know. I mean the
balls to be like, well that's what we are.
We're a nation of immigrants. That's the
whole country. This is ridiculous. Yeah,
it's, it's really taking advantage
of the fact that these poor people,
you know, they're going to be here
whether we like it or not. So let's just,
you know, you got to find a
way to make it work. I mean,
the worst part of that whole thing is,
is when you have people
who came here illegally,
had kids here who are
now an American citizen,
and we're going to ship the
parents out. I mean, that's crazy.
I didn't like doing that to your kids.
Like how
awful. It's awful. And
for the longest time,
the kids weren't able to go to college.
The kids,
if they were born in another country,
like if a kid was a baby
in another country and the
mother said, you know what?
I need to raise my son in America.
This is too dangerous where I live.
I'm going to take a chance.
I'm going to get in a fucking a cargo
car and hide and make it to California.
And they do it. They get through all that.
Their kid grows up in America, the kit,
and then they can't kid
can't go to college because
he's illegal. Now they can.
But for the longest time,
that was the dilemma of the children
of illegal immigrants who were born in
another country that were smuggled
over here for their own future,
for their own safety.
And people that are concerned
enough about their kid's future,
they're willing to risk their own
life to bring them to another country.
I mean it's,
it's a huge commitment and it's a
political pawn is what it becomes.
It becomes his political pond
where people are looking at it.
And if you're on the right, then you
support tough immigration and you know,
strengthen our borders and stop the
flow of illegal immigration into this
country.
And if you're soft and you're,
you're one of those a bleeding
heart liberals, then you decide,
well listen, we need to take care of these
people. We need to set up, you know, and,
and make it so that they can have
access to all the things that we pay for.
Because there are unfortunate.
Somewhere in the middle lies the truth.
And I think the idea that these
people just are here and then we just,
they're illegal immigrants and we
don't address the issue at all.
They just sort of stay here.
That's what we do in California.
There was a there wasn't
there a movie about that?
Like the day the Mexicans left la?
It's like a comedy where
everything's shut down. Yep.
Well you can better believe that
if you're talking about our city,
if like if you kicked out like
hypothetically every illegal person,
this shit would not function.
Shut down. Completely shut down.
So what the fuck kind
of game are we playing?
Pretend in this thing that they're not a
part of us. Oh, it's crazy. They totally,
whatever your position is there.
One undeniable truth is that the economy
functions a huge part of it because we
have illegal immigrants working in it
and that goes not just for southern
California. That's across the
board. Across the board. I mean,
and other countries or in other cities
in the country it's probably less
significant, but here it's
fucking gigantic. It's a lot.
It's a whole lot. The idea that we
just let that stay that way and just,
Eh, it's a mess. It's complicated.
It's a political issue because you can't
say that you want to do immigration
reform because you're going to
lose the vote of the Latinos,
the Latinos that are here illegally.
The last thing that they're going to
want is you to say that you're going to
make it tougher, so you're
going to lose that vote. Yeah.
So you have to decide by vote. But if you
say that you're going to, uh, you know,
you say that you're going to let
them in and they're gonna, you know,
make it easier, then you're gonna lose
the vote of the hardcore. Right. Right.
You're going to lose a
lot of the corporations,
which are probably benefiting
on using immigration labor,
and it's certainly
better flavor.
Certainly benefiting on the shit like
they did with the WTO and they started
moving factories down in Mexico.
There's a lot of God damn corporations
that benefited from that. Yeah.
It's so funny,
like how you know that you can always,
the corporations support whatever makes
them. Of course, I don't give a fuck.
They're not real.
You know,
there are a construct and a construct
designed to create more numbers. Yeah.
It's all they are.
They,
the fact that there's people
running it is inconsequential.
It's essentially a machine unto itself.
So moneymaking machine.
Literal moneymaking machine.
Yeah. Like, um, this is not
labor related, but like, um,
what Carl Icahn's trying to do now to
apple? What's he trying to do? Well,
he's a big shareholder and you know,
he's,
he's a famous corporate raider and so
he's trying to get apple to do a massive
buyback because they're sitting on
a board of cash over a $145 billion.
That's amazing.
Hash,
not like v perceived value
of a share cash money.
Yeah.
They're like bigger than most countries
is a bigger than big investment bank
firms. Well, they're bigger
than the United States really?
Because the United States is in
debt. Yeah. There's, are there,
they're just were trillions of
dollars in desks. Best money making.
I mean it's a lot of cash and he's
like you guys trying to do what?
He's trying to get them to
buy back shares of Apple.
So if you own a lot of you own stock,
basically apple would have to use some
of that cash to benefit the investor.
The guy that owns stock in apple will now
make money because they're buying back.
So they would buy back
their shares in return.
They would be the bit the share
price would go through the roof.
So it'd be like if you own stock,
you're,
you're going to be increased in value
and they would be a private company then.
Well they wouldn't buy back all
of it. Yeah, just a some of it.
And he wants them basically, you know,
do something for the investor. Yeah.
Do something with all that
cash and saw that cat.
But see apple doesn't want
to bring that cash back.
It sits overseas so that they don't have
to pay these crazy high corporate tax
rates are already apple. They have so much
money though. Dirty, dirty, dirty apple.
Get that money back into circle.
Having conversations with them.
But if they are unwilling,
then Mr I can will bring something to the
board and the shareholders meeting and
people will vote on whether or not
to to go through with this buyback.
Wow. I never thought I'd be on the side of
a corporate raider. Yeah, I know. Right.
And He's worth, by the
way, $20 billion himself.
He's probably wants the biggest
yacht ever. It's just like, damn,
if I just make this happen, then I'll
get the biggest yacht ever. Yeah.
I mean he's, he's just, he just, I
think he's in it. He just loves this.
He loves it. It's not about I
need, you know, more money. Yeah.
People who say that there's no, I don't
need money. I don't need much money.
I agree with you.
It's,
you're better having a happy life
doing what you want to do then having
tons of money and being unhappy.
Yeah.
There's something to be said for
being a guy who was $20 billion.
Cause I know, me personally,
if I had $20 billion,
I could make a lot of shit
happen. Okay. I could,
I could make a lot of shit happened.
I think I would,
I would start restructuring society. If I
had 20 billion fucking dollars, I would,
I would make some moves.
You could, you could,
you almost have a
responsibility you do to do. So.
The idea that you couldn't
do good with $20 billion,
you know what kind of community centers
you could set up with $20 billion.
You know what kind of educational
foundation's research foundations,
how much money you could
give to applied sciences,
and how much money you can give to
the right politicians. $20 billion.
That's kind of the principle behind that
giving pledge is they're like, you have,
you have world changing
money, so why don't you, you
know, do something, but you,
you got your houses and yachts and planes
like, you know, let's make some changes.
The amount of money those guys have.
When you really stop and think of this
big corporate raider type characters,
you know those houses. You ever see
those houses in the Hamptons? Yeah.
We fly over and they look
like castle and you just go,
I didn't even know this existed.
These 30 acre compounds with
these 50,000 square feet homes.
And you're looking at
it like what is that?
I mean the staff running
that home is its own economy.
Well Evander Holyfield how to
house in Atlanta. I remember that.
And it was like 110 rooms and it costs
more than a million dollars a year to
run, to run a million. It's a lot.
A million Tommy buns.
That means he's,
he's paying $100,000 a month in his home.
Just take none of his house. Yeah. Wow.
And that has house fucked him.
He had to unload that house or
you don't even think he did?
I think they took it from,
I'll get from him. Oh,
who the fuck's gonna buy that
thing? Did you see, by the way,
when we were talking we were having
dinner. Go to a man that's Tyson's house.
Tyson's house was dog shit
compared to have vendors is crazy.
So Tyson's house that they,
he abandoned in Ohio. It was,
I don't know why he bought a
house in Ohio either, by the way.
Is He from Ohio? Yeah, no, Mike
Tyson grew up in Brownsville.
There was born in Canton or Akron or
something? No, no, no. He was born,
he was born in Brooklyn. Okay. Well let's
find out. Yeah, he's in New York. I've,
well I know he lived there.
I think it's book Brooklyn born.
And then you know the training with the
customers up in was in a at some point
maybe. Right? Cause there's Catskills
and then maybe later there. Yeah,
I'm pretty sure he was born in
New York. Uh, it doesn't say here,
it just says he's a 47. It doesn't
say his place of birth. Wow.
Looking in his a Wiki.
Can't find it yet.
Born in Brooklyn. Yeah. How
dare you Jamie. Goddammit.
JV disinformation doing
buy our house in Ohio though.
Cause he will,
just because someone buys a house in Ohio,
it doesn't mean they're from Ohio.
There's a lot of B. You're downgrading
Ohio son and you're from Ohio.
So how dare you. He's, he's just
real enough that buckeyes lost.
Is that what it is? He's a
little poor bastard. It's a
little butt hurt over that.
You guys party sports.
You guys are talking shit.
I don't know nothing about in and
out. We're done with it. The um, uh,
vendor Holyfield house, pull that shit
up if he can because it's quite stunning.
The grounds just the ground.
So it was like a giant golf course when
we were talking about like how crazy,
you know, may whether lives, I was like,
fuck packy I was the
one who's going to come.
You see how he was having money
problems. Oh, well they took his money.
The government shut all his money off
cause he owes crazy amounts of money.
Right? Allegedly, this is what he says.
He paid taxes in America on his winnings.
They want him to pay taxes again for the
Philippines. Oh my God. And he's like,
look, I already paid. And they're
saying he owes $50 million. Oh my God.
So they took all his money.
They just took it all.
So like he wanted to help the tsunami
victims or the typhoon Holyfield's house.
Oh my God. And they, uh, they closest
bank accounts. Look at Holyfield's house.
My God,
when you see this house,
just go back to the outside photo again.
Look at the fucking size of that.
That's so crazy.
Can you pull back and see like
in perspective with the ground,
see if they have one
that shows the grounds.
It looks like the 409 rooms built Morris.
Oh my God.
Fucking aerial view.
Yeah.
Isn't it amazing that within a couple
of decades all that money has gone?
Like that guy was making so much money
when he beat like when he beat Riddick
Bowe and back when he was
the heavyweight champion,
he beat Mike Tyson 30 $40 million paydays,
right? Like I think, I don't know,
I would assume that he was like make,
I don't think anybody made the kind of
money that Floyd Mayweather it's making
now for weight may, whether it's making
like a hundred million dollars a fight,
like he might make $100 million
for the Canelo Alvarez fight.
It's because he's also a promoter and he,
and nobody sells paper views.
Like that fucking guy. He's
a wizard. Yeah, he is. He's
selling it for 7 million.
What?
109 rooms? Is that what it says? It
says he's sold it for 7 million square.
Pull back on that.
That is fucking insane.
Cost more than 1 million annually to
maintain. What are you selling it for?
7 million. He sold it for
11.5 billion. Uh Oh my God.
$230 million child support cases
in Georgia, Texas and California.
He's double digit. Yeah. I
like shooting loads and girls.
It's fun. It's fun. It feels good.
It's best thing. Best thing ever.
He just didn't give a fuck, I guess.
Yes. Not Man, but that's crazy.
What's your out support payments?
Eight APP is $230 million.
Yeah.
You know, you, you, you,
you know, you hear stories,
you know,
I know a girl who's sister tried to get
a guy pregnant by taking the condom out
of the trash and less and squirting
it into our body. Really? Yeah.
It was like a basketball player or
something like that. Yeah, that's,
that's like a big thing in NBA circles.
Cause like it hosts show up.
I know a guy who works for a team
and he's like, he's like the, the,
like the whole patrol.
Like they show up and they know,
always know the hotels and they, they
make themselves available. These guys,
you know, like they are, they're
wanting to get pregnant, I'm sure. Yeah.
So they really have to, you have
to really, what are you get it man.
And then they just, they know the process.
They like, they have the, they have like,
they're already set up with the
lawyer for when they get pregnant too.
How to the file for a child support.
Like it's already ready to go.
That's just the, the, the goal is
pregnancy. Well, it's like those, uh,
those accident attorneys at UC, like
late night. Have you been injured? Right.
Do you need medical assistance? Did you
take comm? Are you in pain? Yeah. Yeah.
Did you take on, did you get pregnant by
a basketball player? We have a solution,
so they probably just have like,
would you like to make 25 35 $45,000 a
month just for letting your pussy gang
meeting called me. Yeah. That's
amazing that people would do that,
that they would actually bring a
life into the world just for profit,
just for profit. Absolutely.
But when you think about it,
if you've got no money and
then all of a sudden the,
the possibility of making $35,000 in
Monticello and having a kid that you love
so much money to somebody who's
not making money. Yeah. Oh my God.
And it'll give you a status.
You know,
if you carry it around like some
famous guy, Allen Iverson's kid,
sure you get status,
but I got some bad news for you.
If you had Allen Iverson's kid
might not get that checked as well.
He was another one. Right? How much money,
that guy making his career
over 200 million. It's gone.
It's funny that we were talking about
Lotto winners and how they fucking fall
apart. These guys got earned their money
from their skill and it's all gone to,
it's to like a hundred million,
$200 million did.
He made crazy money playing and he had,
he had significant endorsements. I mean,
that was a guy making 20
and 25 million a year,
year after year after year. This, this
hurts my feelings. Yeah. It's really,
it's really upset. It really does. It
hurts my feelings. I can't understand it.
I don't understand that. My
why, why wouldn't you take like
10 million? Put it somewhere. Just 10.
You just, you wish, man, you wish you had,
I'm sure. I mean, I'm
sure that would make,
that would be so much money to
him right now. You gotta go,
I got that 10 standard. Yeah.
Just live in a nice neighborhood.
Buy a decent house for half a million
or whatever. It just live normal lives.
Normal. Abnormal I think
was, it's so much and like,
you know, like especially like in
basketball where your money's guaranteed.
You made like 20 million this year and
you spent crazy and they're like, dude,
you got another hundred 30
coming. You, do you remember Iran?
Barkley who? Iran Barkley. I ran
Barkley was a world champion.
Boxer beat Tommy Hearns, uh,
fought. Roberto Duran fought,
fought some of the greats. Uh, it was
homeless, made millions, millions dogs.
And one of the things that he said,
it was the,
there was a problem with
him when he was younger.
It was a keeping up with all his friends,
like you became friends with all these
rich athletes and they would all like,
you know, I, Hey, I got this new
bands, Hey I got this new house. Hey,
I got the end that he would try
to keep up with them, you know?
Yeah.
They focus on that on the key,
the competitive part of athletes with
money on that documentary broke that Billy
Corbin made.
What is that
documentary?
Cause Billy Corbin is fucking awesome.
He's awesome guy that did
cocaine cowboys. Yeah. Yeah.
So he's done two documentaries
for ESPN 30 for 30 series.
One was about,
is called the you and it's about
University of Miami's football program and
dominance and how they basically came
from nothing to just crazy heights of just
five, you know, uh, BCA or
five national championships.
And then the other one he made
was called broke. And it just,
it's about athletes who
have basically spent it all.
But one of the parts of that when they're
talking about sort of the psychology
of how you end up going broke is
the guys were saying, you know,
I show up,
you show up at the practice
facility and like Joe's got, um,
you know, a Ferrari f four 30 and
you're like, God damn, he's like,
check this shit out man. And then you're
like, that's nice. Fuck, I got a top Joe,
I'm a go get a Lambo Aventador tomorrow
and show up what's up man, check out,
matched it. And then you each just spent
400 grand that week, you know, like,
so if you're always doing that,
you know,
and then you show up with a new
chain and like that's a nice chain.
I got to show up with some hot shit too.
Like it's the same thing about us shooting
pool and racing on the track and you
know,
hitting the bench press,
that competitive thing that goes
into then the money spending.
So you're always in it. And
if you're talking about,
you know, team 50 teammates,
you know, you're, you're just
competing, you're always competing.
Everybody's just buying bigger. And
crazier ship and no one telling you this
really bad idea.
Taking care of families to Bernie
Kosar took care of 50 families,
50 families responsible
for financially 50 50. Why?
Why, why? Why was he responsible?
He felt third response to be
like, this says in the, and the,
this article is about
it. It says that, uh,
they called it the hitting to get a
lottery and they felt a responsibility to
take care of their friends and family
like all her eyes and was taking care of
40 people. Oh my God. Pretty Costar. Say
Travis Henry families. He's the, he's the,
yeah.
All time.
Travis Henry is the all time great as
far as fucking making kids with a lot of
people and then having,
what
can you, it says, this is nine kids
with nine moms for 17,000 per month.
Look at this, but hold on a
second. Look at this part.
But it's not just known friends and
families that hound these instant.
It's also young
ladies with an eye for upward mobility.
One restaurant owner in the nation's
Capitol confessed that she had 7,000 women
who would receive an automatic text
message every time Michael Jordan walked
into the joint during
his stretch as a wizard.
Typically over 2000 women would
heed the call. Of course he's rich.
Young ballers aren't exactly turning leads
the way either. That is unbelievable.
So Jordan would show up at a place in 2000
women would show up to meet him there.
He's having a thousand women would get
the text message. Michael Joe, Oh my God.
Imagine the pussy that has been thrown
at Michael Jordan. It's not even,
you can't even wrap your head around. You
know what it's like? It's like locusts
step outside.
Oh yeah.
He says multiple suits now
for people that are like this.
This is your kid and he's actually
won suits and he keeps winning.
He's winning them because theirs,
that's how you know he's so famous.
I think there's probably people that did
feel like you did fuck me. He's like,
I didn't make a kid with you. Well,
this is also probably, I'm sure,
but there's also probably people that are
like hoping that he'll just pay him x.
Of course she's shut up. Here's some,
here's 300 grand of shut up. Yeah. Yeah.
But you can't just keep doing that.
No.
Especially when you're not
making money anymore. I mean,
how much those Hanes commercials
pay. Oh, he makes unbelievable money.
Still doing what? Well, his shoe
brand is the absolute crazy.
Oh, that's his, that's his journey.
His Nike owns his brand of Air Jordan,
but he is a huge,
huge benefactor of that Bruh.
And he is the number one chew,
uh, among like that
basketball shoes are a huge,
huge multibillion dollar business.
His shoes still outsell Lebron and Kolby,
which is and has been done for
years. That's so crazy. Yeah.
I would say that Michael Jordan's
still probably makes, um,
probably like $40 million
a year. God, yeah.
He's, he's, as far as business
goes, he has set up, man.
That's unbelievable. Wow. Yeah. I didn't
even think about the sneakers, but it's,
it is incredible when you hear about a guy
who was so awesome that still to this day,
it's amazing.
His name rings in the hallowed halls.
They do that.
Oh look, I'm sorry I was off
by 40 million. God. Yeah,
but how many athletes can say that? None.
None. He's number one. They do that.
That I think it's like a Q rating where
they rank the impact of just athletes
and the top 10 is like always the
craziest list of guys who you all,
we all know who they are at Tiger Woods,
right?
I mean Michael Jordan is number one.
He's been number one for like 25
years and the lowest he ever dipped,
he went to like number two once under
tiger woods. Probably pissed. Very pissed.
I bet he was. Yeah. Yeah. He apparently,
if you beat him in a game of pool,
he won't talk to you for two weeks.
I bet. Yeah. They fucking crazy.
He's just completely and competitive
still. They showed him playing at a hotel.
He was playing beer pong with like these
people a few weeks ago and you could
see him, he's fucking focused on shot
shooting ping pong balls into cups.
Seems like it would be unfair.
He would know more about the dynamics of
things bouncing in the average person,
you know, he took that shit
super seriously. He did.
He's going to be one that knowledge and
if you won that he was like fuck that
round two is up right now.
Double or nothing or nothing.
Definitely just stacks of money on the
table. He's bringing into two suitcases.
Yeah. Yeah. Apparently
he's like that with golf.
That's how they say they say in golf.
He is a maniac and he,
he actually,
there was an article that
was written about him,
I don't know if it's true or not,
but some guy who claimed that he owed
millions of dollars or half a million.
It was a book about it.
There's a book about it and he,
he was a thing is that he
is a notorious gambler.
He's actually a really good golf golfer.
Like, he has like a real game, you know?
And he would know wouldn't,
it wasn't uncommon for him to bet a
quarter million on a round of golf.
And he would also, um, they said
like, when he goes to Vegas,
he does, you know, Shit like that for
fun because he makes 80 million a year.
So he's an incredible, what a weird
life that guy has. Yeah. It's amazing.
And he's getting married. He got
married. He got married. Yeah.
Something Young Hottie too.
She's so hot. Ooh. Well Cuban,
I think she's a half Cuban or a Cuban.
Just like fuck it.
I'll just give her a little piece.
Yeah. Give a little piece of this cash.
You think that's, um, pretty airtight
prenup you'd get when you're married.
Michael Jordan.
Oh,
I imagine it goes through several
layers of lawyers looking for,
and when your lawyer sends it
back, they're like, listen.
Yeah. Do you like him?
He want this to work. There's no, there's
no other lawyer this just sign it.
You can't, you don't negotiate.
You get 23 and you for life.
It's a good deal. Right. And
he's just a maniac gambler.
Just gone off with an 80 million
a year coming in every year.
And that's why you can't say
shit about what he was gambling.
I lost $1 million gambling today.
10 years plus he's making like a hundred.
You mean, think about that. It's so crazy.
$100 million a year close to it for 10
years. I mean, how long does it take?
Does he have a billion? Do you think he
has a billion? I think civilian, yeah.
I mean, if you make an 80 million
a year, and he was famous for,
I don't know if it was him
or his agent at the time,
but he's famous for being
one of the innovators in the,
when he was getting these
crazy, um, endorsement deals,
he was getting stock as part of his deal.
So like,
he would get millions of
dollars to sponsor, you know,
to be the endorser of Gatorade, but
then insisted on owning stock. Well,
guess what? When Michael Jordan
started endorsing Gatorade,
stock went up pretty
significantly and he made many,
many more millions than he would have.
So he's pretty innovative
in that sense too.
It's incredible when you hear a guy like
him and then you hear a guy like Tyson
who's telling story now
on HBO. Yeah. It does it in a Broadway
show of how I lost $300 million.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, the
difference in the two, it's, it's,
it's significant. It's not, you
know, another thing is to basketball,
you're not getting hit in the fucking
head at helps getting hit in the head
definitely increases your amount of
shitty decisions that you make. Yeah.
Without a doubt. Yeah, no doubt. I mean,
think about how Shitty your brain
works when you're exhausted. Oh yeah.
Now think about after an exhausting fight
of getting fucking thumped in the head
for 12 rounds. Now think about doing
that over the course of 20 plus years,
a lot of cloudy judgment.
This is going to be some shitty decision.
Makes some shitty 109 room houses that
you have built and they're like a Vander.
Um, you know how much this is
going to cost a lot of money. Um,
don't worry about it.
God will provide real deal.
Jesus will provide me with my bounty.
Okay.
He's still fighting Avengers
fighting. Yeah, I believe so. Yeah.
I think he just tried to a fight
recently and he couldn't get a,
I think it was a,
maybe it was.
Here's what I want to note is
Riddick Bowe still fighting
cause that wasn't good at a while ago.
Uh,
he fought recently in a Moitai fight.
Really Sad.
It was really, really
sad. He got leg kick.
He got stopped by leg kicks, but
it was just devastating man. Yeah.
He's 51 years old and uh, he's still
fighting. You're still trying to fight.
He still looks good actually.
And he's,
as far as like boxers
go talks pretty good.
Oh my Evander. Yeah. Yeah. Not Bad. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, people are still talking
about him fighting. I mean, who knows.
Wow.
Holly F four hours ago,
this is crazy.
Four hours ago a Evander Holyfield
mansion fails to sell at auction.
It's failed to sell. Yup. Back on
market. It's back on the market son.
Um,
it was a 6.8 million.
Wow. It's back on the free market
for 6.8 million. They tried.
Okay.
So it was purchased by JP Morgan Chase
last year for 7.5 million after he
defaulted on its debt. So then they
tried to sell it at mark at a auction.
Nobody wanted it.
And now it's on sale for 6.8 million.
That is a fucking steel you've gotta be
able to do to make money on that somehow,
man. No, no, no one cares.
No, I'm saying make money.
Like if you buy it now, like if you were
to buy that house, I doubt it. Yeah. No,
the the only reason why no one's buying
it is because they can't make money on
it.
I mean to have a house like that,
you got to check how's it going to sit
on the market for a long fucking time and
who's going to buy it? Is it going
to be some new Lebron James Type Guy?
That's the only type of guy that's
going to buy it. Right. And even then,
they're going to look at the
angle of 109 fucking rooms.
Do I need a hundred night? No, I like 2020
yeah, 20 is good. And a basketball
court. Yeah. And then like,
well we can get you that. I'm like, yeah,
let's do you get that and
you get like 89 other rooms.
Why don't you want this day deal? Got
Staff everywhere. Of course it's cool.
Do you like living in the shining house?
It should be a, it should be like,
it should, they need to reach out to
like some Middle Eastern, you know,
some baller by type dude who was a boxing
fan, but it's not seem Ahmed's friend.
Just uh,
just maybe one day I'll go to Georgia
cause by that and we'll stay there for a
paltry 6.8 million, you
know, a guy and a lot man.
One of those salt number NY
type characters. Oh really?
Buy this shit up with the,
the quickness son. Give
me that shit. Did you, uh,
did you check out my, um, special
bombing episode that I heard? No,
you told me about it. We were talking
about it before the podcast. We,
it's funny where all like almost
three hours in we were going to,
we really mentioned it or two hours
in. Um, what the fuck happened?
You were up in Winnipeg?
I A Winnipeg, I was um,
doing this club that I've done many
times called rumors. It's the old club,
it's a good club and it was a Saturday
night and instead of like regular comedy
club crowd,
it happened to be like private event
people like a group of 80 was doing their
corporate party, you know what
I mean? So it wasn't like,
it wasn't individuals buying one
and two tickets, giant group,
giant groups. So there was like
three groups. One was like 81 was 60.
So you don't like,
it's more like you're doing a corporate,
like you're doing a private event, you
know, and I talk, I break it down if you,
if you want to listen to,
it's episode one 72 of your mom's house
and I play the audio from this thing
falling off the rails.
And I mean it is like there was
a lady who worked at the club,
she's been there 20 years and she told me,
she goes,
I've never seen shit like that. Even close
to that before what happened? It was,
I mean I think it's like a,
a combination of things happening to them.
They fall apart that way.
Basically. I went up there,
I had one guy in the
front row who I fucking,
you know when you just hate somebody
and you fixate on them because like this
one guy who was like kind of mumbling,
talking, tagging my everything I saw no.
He's like, yeah, I bet you'd
like that. And you're like,
what? What did you just say?
And I said,
I said one of those guys who I
fucking absolutely lost my shit.
I didn't lose my shit on them,
but I kind of tried to straighten him out.
And then there was one of the groups,
one of the groups of like 50 50 60 people
was like being super loud and like the
first like really talking about
when I went to talk to them,
they were kind of like just like kind
of shitty about it and the thing is like
it's different when you,
when you do a regular show and you,
let's say you go after somebody
or you go after a table,
you're just working on five people.
Maybe write a group that like,
but then everybody else in that room
has nothing to do with them. Right.
In this case it was more like mob
mentality where when I was like, hey,
go fuck yourself. Then the group
is like, you're talking to us.
Not you're not.
You're not just talking to them.
You're talking to my group of
80 so then it was like, no,
fuck you like,
but in in unison there's all
of them and then it just went.
Then I tried to put it back on the
rails, which I was like, I'm sure I can,
I've done this a thousand times.
Let me put this back together.
Fuck you man. Like it was like, dude,
they were booing in unison
for like 1520 minutes.
The 80 people at this point,
it was more than their group.
So it was probably 200 people doing that.
All my God.
So is their group and then
other groups chimed in. So yeah.
Boone you two unrelated groups.
Yes. Yes. Whoa. It was pretty crazy.
And then they're like,
bring back the,
I had a black feature act to
like bring back the Black Guy,
like screaming that screaming it man.
And it went and I, here's the thing,
I resigned to the fact that it was
so crazy. It was less emotional.
I talk about this on that episode
then your standard bombing,
like when you're bombing and irregular
bond where it's just not going your way
and you start to sweat and you're like,
man,
this fucking sucks chewing Dick's up
here. But like, and that and that,
like emotionally affects you.
This was different in that I felt like
their response to me was so outrageous.
Like I felt like it was unwarranted.
How upset they were that it affected me
less. Like I was just standing up there.
I was like,
all right guys here we ready for some
more jokes as they're booing me, you know,
like not as, I wasn't as flustered as
I've been during a regular real bomb.
Yes. So you were just dealing with a giant
group of cons. Yes. A school of cons.
Yes. Swimming through
your pond. Yeah, exactly.
Why didn't the club do something about
that? That's, that's the only part I, I,
cause I take responsibility, I'm,
I try to make it clear on that,
on that episode that like I'd take
responsibility for yelling at a guy,
for insulting people.
Like I'm saying,
I put it on myself that I
made things go downhill.
The club takes responsibility for kind
of not really policing and they like the
one part is I tried to, I told the
guy that he had to go, I was like,
you have to go, you're gone.
See you later. And you know,
I've done that before. Sometimes you have
to do that. You're Outta here man. Right.
And then they were like,
the club came into and they're like,
just give him another chance. He's
going to be good now. When I was like,
I've already thrown them out, like there's
no, we're not negotiating now. Right.
So the club asked to keep the guy there.
Yes. So that part of that, I don't know.
But they, they, now
that that was fucked up,
like I've talked to them and
they were like, that was,
that was some people you can give
a second chance. I've most likely,
most of the time I've asked clubs to
leave people alone like that. Yeah,
they're okay. They're okay. Yeah.
They're just not do that again.
And he'll say that. I'm like,
yeah, you can't yell shit
out. Just too, too confusing.
I've done that a bunch of
times. Like he's okay. Right.
But this time the difference was this time
I was saying, get them out of him out.
What was he saying to you? Well, this
is going on. He was, it was the fucking,
he was the Mumbler the
the tower, right? Like,
so we had our first interaction,
we had another interaction.
I think the third time I said
something to him, I was like,
what the fuck did you say? I
forget exactly what he said.
And then I was like, oh,
you're a tough guy. And he's like, do
you wanna step outside and find out?
And I was like, you can go outside
cause you're out of here. You're done.
Get out of my fucking show. It's my show
out of here. And they were like, what?
And His table. He goes, we all go
and go, great. Have a great night.
Get the fuck Outta here. I don't need you
here. That's when the crowd, the problem,
we felt like we were
discussing what happened.
I was talking about it with the club.
The guy is that a lot of people in that
room didn't hear what he was saying.
He thought I was just attacking
a guy for no reason. Right.
That makes sense. But I still would, I
take, I was an asshole that night. That's,
you know, the guy was clearly,
he was instigating it.
Yeah. He was a fucking cunt.
He was a real kind of guy and I
didn't like him at all. And you know,
I don't think that like,
like I always say I,
I don't have to be like
pleasing to the different,
like I, you know, I'm there doing comedy.
You came to see my standup if you want,
if you're not liking it, that's cool.
But if you try to take over the room, no.
Well it's not just taking over the room.
It's interfering. Yeah. It's interfering,
interfering with the performance.
And there's hundreds of other people
that have to deal with the fact that you
have to deal with this guy.
Yeah. Yeah. It just, it's,
it's all in how to do it and not lose
your cool and when you lose your cool.
Yeah. So it's a fucking, it's bad
scene. Terrible feeling too. It's crazy.
And the audio is insane,
Zane.
I mean, you've probably not heard a lot.
I like that. Yeah. It's a different,
it's not like a standard bombing.
I mean there's,
there's a lot of aggression from the
crowd on it. And how does it end?
Well the best part and the only,
cause I also was bummed at myself for not,
I was like, I, you know, you always
look at moments where you're like,
I wish I had said something
funny. You're here. Right.
This was an opportunity to be
funny. I'm really, you know,
so I was like a lot of it,
I was like, I was like, ah,
you know, I really, they won.
Like they defeated me. I was like, but
the only funny thing I'd said was like,
at one point the manager came up to this
stage and he was like, are you okay?
Like he was checking out. He came on
stage and was like, cause it was so crazy.
And then he's like, Yo, all right.
I was like, yeah. He's like,
do you want to keep you
long? I was like, yeah.
He's like,
okay,
leaves. And they're like,
yeah, that's right. Get the,
cause they think he's telling
me get offstage and I go, I go,
he asked me if you guys wanted
me to bring back the other guy.
And they go, yeah, they scream.
Yes. And I go, I told him,
you guys want more of me so here I
am for more jokes. And they're like,
so they go so crazy at that point.
These are Canadians too. Yeah,
they go fuck the nicest people ever.
But in the very end,
the lady who was running the,
one of the private events that night,
like she brought her group there,
she was in tears, she was crying
and they brought her on stage.
They were like, she wants to say
something. And I was like, oh,
because my plan was just stay here
the entire time, no matter what.
Talk about recipes that you want to
try and just Dohuk these them. Yeah.
She gets up there and she's like, please,
I know I've done fundraisers here.
Like I really wanted
this to be a good night.
And I see like how like she's
a right way affected by this.
Please give him the respect of just your,
your time and like just let
him talk and they're like,
it's too fucking late for that fuck.
Like they're going crazy. Oh right.
And I see her like just
like she's defeated.
It was like someone was beating her up,
you know, and I was like, oh my God, I go,
you know what,
this is 35 minutes in to what's
supposed to be like a 50,
55 minute set,
so there's 20 minutes to go.
I was like, you know what? Um, I don't,
I want her to have a fun night. She like,
she like, it affected me
that she was so, I was like,
I'll tell you what because you're a
nice lady and blah, blah, blah. I go,
I'll bring back the black guy.
And so I brought the black guy back
on stage and they went fucking,
it was like I said, ladies and gentlemen
[inaudible] Chapelle Yeah. He went crazy.
I was like, dude, it's all
you. He was like, oh my God,
I can't believe people actually
like black people here.
Like he was so excited to see you have
any more material. Yeah. Yeah. He had me,
him, his name is, I'm actually giving
credit to his name is, uh, tricks.
That's his whole name. Yes. Like
silly rabbit. Trix are for kids. Yeah.
Wow. But I mean like, you know, he
goes, you guys can pull that off.
They could pull shit like that.
Office Tri Double X. I think
so. That's on what episode
of Your Mom's house? One 72.
All right. It's um, it's, um,
it's a, it's a fun episode to listen
to. You did for putting that audio up.
It takes balls. Yeah. I want it to
Amanda Shine. Yeah, there's tricks.
He did a good job, man. I totally
give him credit. Cool. Yeah. Yeah.
That's an interesting story.
I'm going to listen to that podcast.
I gotta get Outta here. I got shit
I gotta do. Let's roll a, what's a,
what's next for Tommy Buns?
What is next?
What are we going to work together again,
man, we gotta we gotta do some gigs.
Yeah, we're definitely going to do,
we're going doing something right.
What are we doing? We do in New York City
in January. Yes. We're doing New York.
We're doing, uh, the grand ballroom
or something like that. And Manhattan.
The Manhattan Center. Yeah. And then, Oh,
December 20 through New Year's.
Christina and I are apps. We're doing new
year's at the DC Improv. Oh, beautiful.
So a club. Yeah, we'll be
there in Washington DC called
the shifter. They'll sign.
You're going to be in Maryland.
It'll be cold.
You're going to be down
there when it's freezing.
Oh
yeah. Very Fun. Well then I'll have a,
I have like 20 new dates
to add to my calendar,
so those will be up for two to 14 so we'll
do a, we're going to do that together.
And what else are we doing? We
doing something else? Um, yes. What?
Phoenix? January 10th and 11th Oh, that's
right. Yes. Oh, good googly Mowgli. Yeah.
So that's, yeah. Phoenix. We're
doing standup live in Phoenix. Uh,
January 10th and 11th. Yeah, that's right.
Is there doing that too? Oh, no shit. No,
no. It's just the weekend. Friday and
Saturday night and have fun. All right,
thanks everybody for tuning in.
Thanks to 1-800-FLOWERS for
sponsoring it for the first time.
We hope he didn't get offended at our
use of bad language. And you know,
descriptions of your fucking
awesome flowers. Guys
buy flowers. What's wrong with one 800
flowers.com. Enter in the code word J,
r e N.
Get yourself a fields of Europe Christmas
arrangement and receive 10 bucks off.
That's a offer code.
J R e when you click on the little
microphone in the right hand corner.
Thanks also to ting,
go to rogan.ting.com and get yourself
25 bucks off your first ting device when
you sign up.
Thanks also to on at.com it's o n n I t
a use a codeword Rogan save 10% off any
and all supplements. We'll
be back next week. Uh,
Shane Smith and Eddie Wong a bolt
together on one show at the same time.
Shit is going to be crazy and Lee
camp will be here next week as well.
He'll also be Wednesday night.
We camp will be with us at the Ice House
with a Tony Hinchcliffe and Ian Edwards
and uh, other people. Lots more.
We'll see Tommy Vaughn's one
thing. Yes. Our good friend.
The met the little charge you there too.
He has a new album out. That's right.
He'll be here soon too. Well, if not
next week, the week after that. Um,
what's it called? Full. It's called, this
is the part of the job I hate, I think.
I think that's what it's called. It's
on how useful. All right. Tommy Bonds,
ladies and gentlemen, Casa Guerra on
Twitter. Follow Him and learn and,
and grow in love and harmony. All right.
We'll see you guys soon. Thank you. Bye.
Okay.